[Music]
please put your hands together for Emily
J Ryan
[Applause]
so welcome everybody to innovators Hive
here at Google Cloud next
so my name is Emily Ryan and I'm leading
our technical customer engineering Cloud
native team for startups and scale-ups
across Europe north and we have the
opportunity to work with developers like
you every day and this is really what we
love most about working at Google Cloud
I'm so excited to be here in Munich
today and thanks to all of you who have
joined us here in person and a big warm
welcome to all you folks joining across
Europe Middle East and Africa online
hello Internet
so
today's event is about sharing the best
technical content across our very broad
platform in a special hybrid setting so
we can really reach all of you where you
are
and in this full day of content you'll
get to hear from our Google Cloud
experts from your local community
members and from our champion innovators
plus you'll have a chance to interact
with some cool demos
you can ask our Google Cloud Architects
about your individual questions and you
can ramp up on skills in our arcade
and what would be a developer day
without swag so we already handed out a
little bit at the beginning but we have
even better stuff as a reward for you
folks attending all of the sessions so
you should have a stamp card and if you
go for the first 10 minutes of a session
at least you'll get a stamp
and then uh you can collect those for
swag at the end of the day
so if you enter the session after 10
minutes your card won't be stamped so
you know German punctuality uh is a plus
today
the more sessions you attend the more
swag you'll earn and if you stay for our
two Hands-On workshops at the end of the
day and you'll get even more stamps so
it's worth it plus we have a party
afterwards so definitely don't go
anywhere
so here in the venue we have two
technical tracks that you can follow so
one in the room here uh and one is
upstairs on the first floor you can look
at the back of your
agenda name tags the agenda is on the
back
so join the sessions from the beginning
to get your stamps each session is only
about 20 minutes long so we're really
packing the content in and then you'll
have a 10 minute transition and break in
between
I'm also super excited to announce that
all of you as attendees of innovators
Hive can register
to get access to the Drone racing
challenge so we created this in
partnership with the Drone Racing League
the DRL to usher in a new era of tech
driven Sports
so you use race data and Google Cloud
analytics tools and developers of any
skill level really from around the world
can predict race outcomes and even give
tips to the drivers and Pilots to
enhance their season performance
you will compete for a chance to win an
all expenses paid trip to the season
finale of the DRL world championship and
be crowned on stage as champions
so outside there's more info for this
and register and super excited to see
who ends up on stage hopefully somebody
from Europe
so we have talks we have games we have
swag we have Hands-On demos we have food
and drink you will be well taken care of
on the ground floor and the first floor
um so really take advantage don't forget
to explore and exchange with our Google
Cloud experts and Talk Amongst
yourselves and really get inspired to
become innovators uh on Google Cloud
so let's get this started for our first
keynote we have all the way from San
Francisco Matt Thompson who's our
director for developer adoption and
Matt's going to share the latest on what
we're doing in Google Cloud to continue
to grow the impact of developers in emea
and around the world we want to make
Google Cloud the most intuitive and easy
to use platform
and we're going to share our continued
investments in critical areas that you
care about most like developer security
data and Ai and just how to get your
apps up and running quickly and safely
so without further Ado welcome to the
stage Matt
[Applause]
good morning
[Music]
good morning
there we go so I wanted to thank you all
for being here um actually I think this
is a very civilized time to start an
event so I appreciate you all being here
I went first heard about the event I was
saying please don't want to start like 8
A.M we have people in New York I was
just in New York earlier this week and
we started the event at 8 30 and I was
like wow that was early and New York's
very crowded hard to get around et
cetera the other thing I wanted to
mention and this is a personal thing for
me so I wanted to thank all of you for
being here in person and I know we have
a huge audience online as well and I
want to welcome all of them and actually
I have a small story to tell my daughter
who is studying computer science at the
university is actually awake right now
on the East Coast United States watching
this
so if I screw up she's going to tell me
I know she will
um but I wanted to say this is the first
time I've been back in person at an
event other than the event earlier this
week and so thank you for joining it's a
huge thing for us to get back and see
and engage in the community firsthand
and I hope you enjoy this
um there are a number of things that
we're going to talk about today
including new features for our clouds
some of the thinking that went behind it
but I want to start with something I'm
going to finish with as well
we build our Cloud for Developers
Google exists as an engineering company
for Developers it's why I joined the
company it's why all the other speakers
that you'll hear from today are part of
the company
and when I was just in New York for the
kickoff of this event
um globally one of the things that was
really interesting is I wasn't meeting
with developers I was meeting with CEOs
and ctOS and cxos from a number of our
top customers it was a great
conversation and I'll share a little bit
of that a little bit later in the talk
but was interesting to me
was that I wasn't talking to people who
write code
and that that was missing so I hope
today we get to explore some thoughts on
the type of code you're writing the
types of applications you deploy and
even if you don't write code all the
time anymore if it's in your background
we still want to hear about that
and we'll talk a little bit about in
this keynote why that's really important
going forward as well
so the other thing I want to mention is
why are we here so much beautiful city
I'll share actually that in the middle
of the pandemic I did take my family on
vacation and we were I'm a scuba diver I
usually have a slide up of me scuba
diving somewhere but one of the things
that we did is we actually finished in
this city our vacation finished in the
city we spent three days here it is an
absolutely beautiful city especially in
the middle of summer
um it was absolutely gorgeous and so why
are we here
because this is the center of innovation
Amia also is a center of innovation and
I want to talk a little bit about that
there's a long history of innovation
within the region
some of that goes all the way back to
CERN where the World Wide Web was
developed
but we see Innovation coming from the
region and across sub-Saharan Africa and
and the Middle East as well and so we're
here because we think this is an
important place to invest our time and
our effort to see what you're developing
and to hear from you what's next
so the other thing is it's a very large
region and and most people don't
necessarily think about this they're
actually more Cloud Developers
in the larger emea region including
Middle East and Africa than there are
anywhere else on the planet today
well more several million more than we
see in North America
and that me that's meaningful it means
that there's a community of like-minded
individuals here innovating developing
bringing new workloads to bear this is a
really important thing for us and why
we're here
so
there's also one more thing I want to
talk about from the perspective of how
we engage with our community so how many
of you familiar you might have heard
from Emily our innovators program how
many of you have heard of our uh Cloud
innovators so it's our developer program
it's free you're going to hear me talk
about it a couple times today we would
like all of you to go sign up for our
innovators program
by the end of today or when you get home
but Insider interviews program we
actually have a tier of what we call
champions
these are Community leaders and
Technology leaders
that have kind of stepped up and said we
want to help
build cloud and have Cloud engage around
Cloud Technologies in all the various
communities in which developers engage
that could be user groups that could be
meetups it could be our own cloud gdgs
interestingly we have more champions
in emea than anywhere else in the world
but actually quite a bit
and that says two things to me it says
that there's a large robust community of
technical leaders in the region
and also that you're very Community
focused and oriented
and those things
make a huge difference when we talk
about the proliferation of innovation
um in regions and I can tell you lots of
stories I've had the opportunity to
travel all over the world to talk to
developers interestingly
part of it is cultural
in some places sharing just isn't
something that you do
here sharing is part of what you do
getting together talking to people
sharing ideas is a key component of this
we all want to learn from each other it
is a human trait
my team is like this I am like this
today I'm hoping to get a chance to meet
with a number of you and just hear the
ideas that you have and what you're
building
so for us this is a key measure for us
and I expect Amia to continue to lead
in this measure going forward so great
job
if there are people in this ecosystem
today in the audience today that are
interested please join our innovators
program and if you're leading
communities if you're influential in
your company come talk to us there are
opportunities to do more
so it's not just about communities
though where do we see actual Innovation
happening
one of the places we look often for
signals for this startups
so startups are interesting because they
tend to consume faster they tend to
adopt faster they also tend to Pivot
faster if a technology is not working
what do they do they go try a different
technology
if they're not if it's not working on
one Cloud they may go work on another
cloud
and interesting for us
startups are a key Focus
we can actually see what's working
what's not at a much faster Pace in the
startup ecosystem and when we talk about
the strategy system for emea it's not
just one location it's not just London
it's not just Paris
it's not just Berlin it's not just
Barcelona it's not just Tallen it's not
just Copenhagen it's across the entire
region and we're seeing it emerging in
other places in emea places like Cape
Town Lagos Casablanca Nairobi
and these startup ecosystems are also
places where we see the great sharing of
ideas as well
so we use this as a measure for us to
see how fast technology gets adopted
what's working what's not working
so I just want to see a show of hands
how many of you would say that you
either work in a startup or have worked
in a startup within the last 10 years
it's a significant population
that's great we love that
that's that's a hunger for Innovation
hunger for learning
we'll go farther it's not just startups
our largest customers also are using
Cloud technology to learn and drive and
so an interesting example here is
Lufthansa
Lufthansa used our vertex AI engine and
our ml tools to figure out how to create
flight schedules that were more accurate
so flights on time how did they do this
they analyzed wind patterns in their
airports
and what this allowed them to do is
forecast with our tools to be much more
accurate and actually they have one of
the highest on-time arrival ratings for
the entire world because of this
so that's an example of an Enterprise
using our technology our Cloud
Technologies and specifically
intelligent data
to build their business model and make
it more effective
so the other thing I want to talk about
is
a little bit so we've got community
we've got
startups adopting technology quickly
we've got Enterprises adopting
technology to add value add value
propositions to their business
what about security what about privacy
these are huge important things in emea
and now worldwide
so interestingly within Google Cloud
we've implemented a number of systems
that allowed you to
protect
data
enable privacy
and so things like the cloud data loss
prevention
and if we go a step farther into
Healthcare did the notion of being able
to have private data
stay private when you're working with
things like Medical Imaging
really important how do you how do you
both for personally identifying
information being able to store that
away and keep it private as well as
private health information
super important
and so we use these things these kind of
scenarios to make sure that we are
building what we hope will turn out to
be the most secure the most private the
most extensible and most powerful Cloud
that exists on the planet
and we know that's a very very important
for the region and by the way Amia is
leading in this area we're now seeing it
emerge in places like Brazil and
Singapore and Indonesia and Japan
we know that this is an important thing
and we expect to deliver on this
and what we say is that these are kind
of cloud building a cloud on Europe's
terms and so we're kind of collapsing it
down from Mia from a moment to here
because they're very specific needs
inside the EU things like gdrp and a
number of other things we expect to
build
the most robust most private
most extensible and most powerful Cloud
on the planet
and we don't just say that we're
actually implementing that
so before we go and talk about our
trusted Cloud for a bit I want to talk
about the other part of this this which
is great building one example of a cloud
bringing one region isn't going to help
the people around the world it's not
going to help developers deliver
their Innovation to all the customers
that they may have in region out of
region worldwide
so what we recently announced is we have
a new Cloud region in Milan it's now
open
on Disney one in Paris
and then just the one in Madrid but
that's not enough
this week we announced
will be bringing new Cloud regions
to Norway Sweden Austria Greece and
South Africa
and for those out there on the internet
listening to this that might be in
sub-Saharan Africa this is part of the
billion dollar investment that Google
announced in spurring innovation in the
region
because not only do we want to enable
reaching customers
across
Europe and the Middle East but also
Africa and so we expect to see
the startup the huge amount of startup
activity that we see in places like Cape
Town Lagos Nairobi and Casablanca
to start delivering Innovation to
customers in those areas as well
in addition to that
we've announced that we're expanding
into with Doha Turin
Berlin
dumbham
and Tel Aviv
these are all Cloud regions that we're
bringing to to Market
over the next months
and what does this allow you to do it
allows you to build locally but deploy
globally
and deploy your services as close to
your customers as you need them to be
this is the largest single investment
that Google has ever made in anything is
these new data centers
and we will continue to grow out we
expect this to be a global front
footprint for local development
so to talk a little bit about our
trusted partner cloud and how we're
approaching this I'd like to ask Julian
to come up on stage and kind of dive
into the details of some of this Julian
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Matt
my name is Julian I'm a googler based in
Brussels I've been working many years
advising organizations around the world
and in Europe to handle sensitive data
sets and workloads on on Google Cloud
to connect to what Matt just announced
to be truly Global we must be local
and indeed for anything relating to
sovereignty we residency is a
first con is a necessary condition
um
however
there is much more to residency to
achieve sovereignty
and these additional abilities are what
makes Google quite unique in how we
respond to the sovereignty expectations
growing everywhere in the world
sovereignty is not about more security
you already benefit from a level of
security very few can match when you
deploy your or your customer services on
you know these these world scale frankly
world-class infrastructure
sovereignty is about trust
every day we meet organizations around
the world that frankly make sub-optimal
decisions when it comes to Innovation
ability scalability resiliency even
security and sadly sustainability
because they lack the trust to engage to
engage on cloud
unless we fix that cloud that trust
issue
also a cloud issue we will not be
delivering on our mission
so what is it exactly that we are
solving for
in countries where we operate
we engage closely with customers but
also regulators and we listen to
lawmakers and we hear three distinct
narratives unfolding the first is very
familiar is all revolving around data
Protection security and privacy since
the arrival of the gdpr
like many others who've been on top of
this
and it's not to say that things are
solved far from there but honestly we
are seeing good development good
tractions and good progress in that
direction both from the technical side
also from the legal side and even from
the political side as we might have read
you might have read last week
there was a second discussion which is
gaining traction these days is related
to the economic imbalances created by
the uneven distribution of technology in
different regions of the world to
paraphrase a French Minister on this
topic we as European have been there
before
we will remember the discussions around
nuclear energy knowledge or commercial
airliners in the 70s
and we have
fix this and we will probably
collaborate our way through this game
again to be back in into into this game
too
the third element is the reality that
any responsible technology decision
makers today cannot abstract the risk of
having certain services not available in
a certain region this might unfold in an
unexpected way by the way we have seen
some countries having to pass laws or
make decisions to get their data outside
of their boundaries recently to keep the
data more protected
um so residency is very important but
access control is Paramount for some of
these Services you or your customers
will want control over these
cryptographic keys
in September 2020 we published a vision
outlining our working Direction
and we stated that sovereignty
while strongly anchored into Data
protection
really goes beyond that and what we are
seeing is a deeper need for operational
sovereignty really the capability for
local Partners to have more if not full
oversight or oversight sorry over the
cloud that their customers are using
locally
finally we embed into the vision the
need for our customers to continue
operate in situations where
connectivity cannot be guaranteed
anymore either for technical legal or
political reasons
delivering on a software sovereignty
vision
a year later in September 2021 we
announced our first Partnerships with T
Systems in Germany tales in France minsa
I.T in Spain and Tim in Italy to
collaborate and develop together a
portfolio of trusted Cloud offerings for
Europe
a year later September October 2022 we
are announcing the first products coming
out of these relationships
Google Sovereign controls
offer the ability
to define the location of your customer
data
control who has access to the customer
data
and keep control over the cryptographic
keys including outside of Google's
infrastructure
if you do not have these three technical
controls you do not have data
sovereignty
you might want to use additional gcp
core services or controls like DLP was
just mentioned to de-identify the data
or confidential compute to keep data
encrypted while in use
our partner managed services or partner
managed solvent controls
add an extra layer of control an ability
for local Partners to control Monitor
and control Google's access to the
customer data and add a layer of
visibility and be full control over you
know operational elements
the supervised Cloud offering when ready
from France and Germany will be operated
by local Partners in country
allowing
to serve specific data sets or specific
requirements meeting specific regulatory
demands like for example the second
cloud in France
finally there are scenarios where less
Reliance on this cloud provider is
necessary in our hosted Cloud Solutions
are
working towards being able to operate in
disconnected fully air gapped
environments meeting the software
sovereignty ambitions
delivering
sovereignty
is not a trivial task not for us also
not for you or anybody having to set
these things up
however we understand its importance and
we're engaging on this journey
to deliver Cloud on Europe's terms a set
of carefully crafted Solutions
uh put together with the local partners
but really aiming to
deliver the true value of the cloud
in a way that is acceptable by your
Global customers starting in Europe
I want to end with a small reflection
we as technologists are basically laying
down infrastructure and infrastructure
can last a very long time
it is not the first time that
infrastructures is laid in times of high
mistrust the railways in the 1870s
electricity after the second world war
and still today when you travel through
Europe and you take the train and you
want to cross from France to Spain you
have to change trains because the rails
have been laid in different widths
our task
is to meet our customers expectations
today
while not contributing to a long-term
fragmentation for tomorrow
having said that Matt
you're welcome back on stage yeah
thank you
[Applause]
so I want to talk a little bit about now
about developers you
um I've been doing this for a long time
I'm not going to tell you how long
because it makes me feel bad but I will
tell you that the first
project I work on
was actually writing a c plus compiler
for a company that doesn't exist anymore
I was actually very proud of doing that
we actually were taking C front
technology throwing it out and writing a
native C plus compiler
and at the time I remember thinking
nobody cares
because the company I worked for didn't
care about C plus compiler
the people who are going to use the
compiler did care but they were using it
because they were trying to create an
interesting application or something
like that the fact that it was C plus
which just happened to be the language
they were using today I'm going to tell
you and I think many of you feel this
way developers have never been more
important
and I want to share a very quick story
about my time in New York just a few
days ago
I was sitting at a table with seven or
eight ctOS cxos from some of the largest
customers that Google has one of them
happened to be a CTO for a large Bank
and he decided to share I asked the
question so how important are your
developers how do you treat them how do
you
how do you recruit them how do you pay
them how do you reward them what role do
they play in your organization and he
said something very interesting he said
we're a large Bank we take we have a
regulatory piece of the business that we
have to account for
and then we have customers both
commercial customers and consumer
customers that we want to provide the
best service to so we set out our uh
what we're trying to do from a business
perspective and that's all done by
Executives and and people like that but
the choice for tooling
application Frameworks
cloud
all of that decided by the Developers
and he said after fighting for 10 years
with developers on trying to tell them
what they need to use he just gave up
and he said it's much more efficient to
let them choose now he said the thing we
always have to be careful about is a
proliferation of tool chains and
everything else so he actually makes the
developers get together and say we are
going for this project going to
standardize this language this framework
this tool set this deployment
environment
but he says it's much better than
anything he's done in the past
and I'm here to tell you that's the
world we're moving to if you don't feel
it today you will feel it in the future
everywhere we go all the developers we
talk to there are examples where
developers are the leading innovators
inside companies
and they have outsized
impact on the decisions being made
that's important that's why we're here
that's why we're talking to you we
believe you hold the keys
to the adoption patterns for the next 10
years
we'd like you to choose Google Cloud
obviously but you hold that ability in
your hands
and so interestingly one of the
important aspects of that is that we all
have to keep learning
I call myself a lifelong learner I
believe in that I'm constantly trying to
learn about new technologies that come
into the market
and so what we've done
is we've built a program to help you do
that as well
we want to increase your commitment to
learning new skills
so a year ago we launched a program
and we made a commitment
that we wanted to
reach 40 million people to increase
their Cloud skills over the next five
years worldwide
and we have our Cloud skills boost
program it's part of that but this week
we added to that
and now what this includes is something
that we're calling innovators plus
similar part of the program where we're
providing Cloud credits certification
vouchers
and opportunities to to engage in Live
Events like this
as part of the subscription
so everybody learns a little bit
differently but if you're interested in
learning through formal programs
sign up today
this is the URL
this is a great way for you to stay get
up to speed and stay engaged with what
we think are going to be the most
important skills in the cloud
environment going forward
so
what we're also trying to do with our
platform
is make it easier for developers
everywhere we've talked about all the
data centers we're opening up we're
talking about the other regions
we want to make it easier for you to do
what you love
and having spent time as a developer I
know people don't like
running down bugs working out deployment
issues trying to figure out why services
are are not as performant in one in one
region versus another those are the
things that we're trying to automate for
you and along those lines I want to talk
a little bit about some of the things
that we've done
so for example
for containerized applications gke
autopilot now will allow you to deploy
and run faster to point six times faster
on Google Cloud than any other Cloud
platform
using Cloud deploy for continuous
delivery 2.4 times faster than any other
Cloud platform
for both for cloud run for serverless
for devops type things
fifty percent faster on our platform
than others
now those are all nice and that's all
the Innovation that we intend to keep on
bringing but there was something we
announced this week that's really
important I just want to stop for a
second because it's not all about trying
to get your code
gets you to deploy to develop deploy and
and operate your code in an easier
environment
we also want you to be able to do it
more securely
so I'm going to take a risk here
I just want to see from a show of hands
how many of you write code today as part
of your job
excellent keep your hands up keep your
hands up
how many of you really deeply inside
care about security keep your hands up
if you do
interesting let me tell you how that
usually goes
all the hands go down with maybe two
for that last one
this is something that I've been
involved in from the very beginning and
something I think is very important so
we announced a new product today or or
this week called the software delivery
Shield it has a number of components I'm
going to talk about
but I'm going to tell you that the goal
of this for the first time is going to
be able to get developers to care about
building secure software
without having to do extra work
so this is not getting you to care and
having you to do more work this is
getting you to care doing what you're
already doing
so we're going to talk a little bit
about this and then we're going to
actually show a little bit of it so
first thing is we've got Cloud
workstations so some of you may have
heard we announced called workstations
this week Cloud workstations is not just
another IDE in the cloud
it is actually an environment a secure
environment that allows remote workers
and contractors and vendors as well as
other Developers
to build securely
and within Cloud workstations
we have what's called assured open
source software
how many of you today
consume open source software as part of
your environment
yeah
here's a question
if your managers are worried like on a
weekly or monthly basis that they don't
know what's in that open source software
yeah it's it's actually a very big issue
so through assured open source software
what we've done
is we've gone through and started with
250
of the most important Java and python
libraries and provided our level of
assurance by doing the testing the
analytics and the fuzz testing against
these so that you can use them consume
them within our environment
completely securely
there are other companies that have
tried this in the past but nobody's done
it at Google scale and we're not
stopping at 250 and we're not stopping
stopping with Java and python
for the first time because we do this
for you to consume open source projects
libraries artifacts Etc we want to make
sure that you feel that it's a
completely trusted piece of software
that you're bringing in your environment
and that's what assured open source
software is all about
in addition
we're adding security into the build
environment So within Cloud build we now
have slsa level 3 support threat
prevention which allows you to trace
back
all the software components that you
bring into your environment
allows you to build an assured fashion
and then last
within gke and serverless we now have
opinionated
deployment options for you so rather
than handing you
and I won't I won't quote the number of
docs Pages you'd have to read
to actually use
um you know gke effectively and figure
out all the different options we are now
providing opinionated views of that so
you can choose one of those
configurations in a completely secure
way
and so what I want to do now is bring
somebody up on stage I call them the mad
scientist Abdul
to kind of rather than just talk about
this show this to you please welcome
Abdul to the stage
[Applause]
thank you Matt
I've been giving the awesome task of
doing a demo so let's see what can go
wrong right
um so I'm very excited to be here
um I'm gonna do a demo and we're going
to talk about this fictional company
called symbol it's an e-commerce company
they sell things online they are based
out of the US and they run on Google
Cloud they have adopted Google Cloud
both in terms of Technology managed
services but also in terms of best
practices and the whole goal of of this
business or really any business is to
run in a secure manner but also remove
Innovative e-commerce is a very
competitive domain
so this is how their microservices looks
like it's just a microservices-based
environment running on gke protected by
our overall solution called the software
delivery Shield
if I get back the demo laptop please
so these are the services in gke as you
can see just pods for those of you who
are familiar with gke running containers
and one of the softwares or one of the
solutions that Matt talked about as part
of the software delivery Shield is this
new thing called the gke security
posture so what it is essentially a
dashboard that gives you an overview of
all your clusters in the project and
tells you both vulnerabilities but also
misconfiguration so let's see an example
I can go to the concerns tab
and I can filter on configuration and I
want to also only look at the high ones
so here I have for example one of them
which is a pod with privileged
containers essentially a port that
Transit containers as roots this is
against uh gke or kubernetes pod
security spec so here I can see which
workloads are affected by this concern
it's not really vulnerability it's more
misconfiguration and if I go back to the
details I have some recommended actions
so basically I have to go and edit the
yaml file and then set the security
context privilege to false
I can also filter on vulnerabilities and
let's just look at the critical ones so
those are vulnerabilities in the current
running workloads right so essentially
what we're doing is we take every image
and we scan it so we just decompose the
the docker file look at each layer and
compare it against the cve database so
here I have a list of all the potential
cves that are that exist in those
workloads again I can look at the
workloads and from here I can take this
and make it an issue or a bug and make
sure that the team can fix it
if you go back to the slides please
now symbol runs in us as well but they
want to expand to Europe let's say they
are planning to just offer their
services in Germany
um they want to use Google Cloud to
expand their presence in local markets
but they want to customize the front-end
they want to make the front end more
local in both in terms of the look and
feel and maybe even the language but
what they're doing also is they're
actually expanding their teams to Europe
so they have a new front-end engineering
team that is going to be working on the
local version or whatever of the fronts
and of the of the app right
they can do that in so many ways one
potential way is essentially keep all
the backhands running in the US on top
of gke and just use cloud run to deploy
the front ends to the region where they
are expanding in our case they will just
have a front-end per country maybe or
front-end for the entire emea
and we're gonna see how they're gonna do
this end to end starting with new
developers who are not necessarily
familiar with kubernetes they don't know
it they don't have to know it you don't
have to use kubernetes for everything
they will be using Cloud workstation
which is our fully managed development
environment in the cloud to to write
code test it locally and then use cloud
build and Cloud deploy to deploy these
workloads while ensuring the end-to-end
security we talked about
so briefly about Cloud workstations Matt
talked about it is a is a is a fully
managed development environment in the
cloud which allows you to write code in
an editor that you are familiar with as
a developer but also to run your code
locally and by locally I mean in the
cloud it's not a new laptop but you
still run on an emulator like Cloud run
emulator you have Pub sub emulations you
have a bunch of emulators everything is
already integrated into the environments
and let me show you how that looks like
if I can get back yeah so this is how
the app looks like that's just very
simple online boutique app I have
products and prices and so on
uh this is my workstation it's already
up and running hopefully
finger crossed
yes it is so it's just a workstation
um what cloud workstations are actually
private instances they are part of the
VPC which means if you're using VPC
service controls or you have arrows in
Ingress and egress policies those
policies will apply to the workstation
one of the advantages of using a cloud
workstation in the cloud is that you can
actually ensure that people cannot
extraviliate code they cannot just dump
code outside of the workstation or that
if somebody get their laptop stolen
people cannot just take code from the
laptop because it's cloned on it
this is how the UI looks like for those
of you are familiar it just looks like
visual code right but it comes
pre-loaded with everything you need to
be able to run code on Google Cloud so
let's just take an example
um as I said earlier here the example
I'm talking about here is we're going to
be able to write a new front end but
make that front-end talk to backends but
because the front end and the
workstation
in this case and also my backends are
all part of the VPC I'm just configuring
my environment such a way I talk to
private IPS so I don't actually have to
expose my backends to the internet
then if I go back to my home page here I
can change this I'm just going to do a
very simple HTML change
save it and then I can simply do
um just bring up the command palette and
run on the Google Cloud run emulator so
the Google Cloud run emulator is just
Cloud run inside the workstation and
that's once I do that it will give me a
port forwarding page and I can see that
my changes have been through right so
this is my developer cycle from code to
testing locally but everything is done
in the cloud
now if I'm happy with this I can
actually go ahead and push code to my
get Ripple I can do it from the terminal
but I'm feeling lazy today because it's
still too early for me so I'm just gonna
go ahead and do it from the GUI right I
think some of you are familiar with this
um environment so I'm just gonna type A
commit message and then just commit my
code right
and basically if I go back to my code
Source I have my commits coming through
I can look at it I have done I have to
admit I have done this yesterday because
you know demos I don't want to risk it
so I have my check my code change and
the other thing I have in my code
repository which I haven't showed you is
I have a cloud built pipeline definition
for for those of you who are familiar
with Cloud build is our CI pipeline
continuous delivery it basically takes a
bunch of instructions and execute them
in order here what I'm doing is I am
running a Docker build which will build
the image and push it to artifact
registry which is where the image will
be stored and the second step is going
to start a cloud deploy pipeline I'm
going to show you that in a bit let's
start by looking at our Cloud build
so this is the build that got executed
yesterday
at 11 PM and it worked
so I have two steps I have build image
and then I have executed a build
pipeline
so one of the new additions to Cloud
build which you might have not seen
before is this new tab called build
artifacts in it I can see that I have a
text file so the text file actually is
the logs so the results of the build and
then I have the image here and I can
directly from cloud build look at the
security exposure or the security
insights for this specific image so
every single image that we push took
artifact registry is scanned and is
tested against the salsa level 3
framework
so I can look at the provenance so the
provenance is you can think about it as
the recipe how this image have been
built so I have a bunch of metadata like
um when was it built who built it how
was it executed what's the command that
ran this that built this image uh when
was it built
etc etc
so this is just metadata that is added
on top of the image and that can allow
me to do further analysis so this
metadata is used actually as an input to
the salsa level 3 compliance salsa level
3 is a a build compliance framework
which was created by sixstar which is an
effort between multiple companies to
make open source safe for everyone and
that's part of the assured open source
that Matt talked about
um so here I can see that my image is
bug free and vulnerability free I can
also look at the same exact informations
in the artifact registry page
which if if I click on it I have the
vulnerabilities page so this will always
show me that my image is vulnerability
free which is great
now
if you remember from the cloud build
pipeline I have also triggered a cloud
deploy pipeline so Cloud deploy is
Google Cloud's continuous delivery
pipeline which allows me to basically do
a CD in this case I have three steps I
have deploy into dev then I can promote
it to stage and then I can promote it to
production
and the three targets are all Cloud run
Services right
so again yesterday I have already
promoted it from Dev to Stage so we can
look at the app in stage so this is my
stage app and it says hello Munich right
so that's the change I made earlier
and then one additional thing I can do
is I can one of the things I can do when
my application is running in stage is I
can actually start doing some
integration testing some load testing to
try to figure out if the app works or
not right
in our case we have intentionally
introduced a little bit of an error on
purpose just to be able to demo this so
we can see here back in October we had
some errors 500 thrown by one of the
backends because you know things can go
wrong it's code now one of the the
interesting things when you are doing
Distribution Systems in microservice
environment is looking at graphs like
this can only tell you what have gone
wrong but it can it cannot tell you
where exactly things have gone wrong you
have to go deep you have to go dig in
the logs to see what have happened and
if you have before used any login
software you know that digging through a
list of logs is not it's not easy so
that's why we have introduced a new a
new solution called log analytics so
what log analytics is it's basically SQL
in Google Cloud logs so you can run SQL
queries and you can query logs across
multiple and multiple lines like
hundreds of thousands of lines it's
powered by bigquery which means
basically whatever amount of logs you
have you can just query them
and I have already written my query and
executed it yesterday so this is the
query I'm basically looking for any log
error or any log that has in the message
this error called place order failure
and then I'm just filtering on the
products ID
and I can see here that I basically have
166k line of the same exact products ID
this means essentially for me that's
actually my error was not caused by code
or a bug in the code it was caused by a
data which is corrupted this is probably
coming from the database
so as any developer would do I'm just
going to ignore this
and I'm gonna go ahead and promote my
app to production right so here what I'm
going to do is I'm going to promote the
app from station production but
before I can do that there is an approve
required right so I'm just going to go
ahead and click approved and this is
normally the time when I just stand up
get a cup of coffee and walk to my
colleague and say can you please approve
my change but because I don't have my
colleague on stage I'm gonna do it
myself because why not right I have
broken production so many times so I
feel very comfortable doing this
so I'm just gonna go ahead and approve
my change
and that's basically will promote my app
from stage to production
this is going to take a little bit of
time so I'm not going to wait for it but
essentially at some point this is my
production Cloud run service eventually
at some point it's going to say hello
Munich you can trust me on that I tried
this before
um the thing with apps generally
speaking is that it's not always only
about code right apps required data and
data is very important and in Google
Cloud we have a bunch of things a bunch
of products that are data oriented but
we also have released a bunch of new
products and I'm gonna bring Matt on
stage to talk to you about this Matt
thank you
thank you thank you
I'm back I I did want to point out
um if you notice symbol doesn't seem to
be selling Abdel shoes I don't know if
you saw his shoes those are custom-made
shoes he's very proud of so next time he
comes out you have to to point out his
shoes so I want to talk a little bit
about and and by the way I should I
should say this
um there were two commitments I made
this morning one was to try to be mildly
entertaining for you and two was to to
the show team to make sure we ended on
time so I am going to speed this up just
a little bit to make sure we absolutely
end on time so I can hold that
commitment
so one of the things I want to talk
about really quickly is about so we've
talked about location we've talked about
secure building we've talked about uh
better manageability for deployment Etc
but we haven't talked about intelligent
apps
right I mean if we look at the future
what does future look like data-driven
applications and intelligent data
so we're going to talk a little bit
about this so first thing I want to talk
about is an announcement that we made
this week with mongodb so for any of you
that are using the mean stack and
JavaScript and mongod Atlas
there are now configuration scripts
available to help deploy those into a
Google Cloud environment really easily
using terraform scripts and if you're
interested in this please go check out
the Google Cloud blog that was written
this week about the partnership and this
is only the beginning of the work that
we're going to be doing together and the
reason why it's important is because we
actually believe we have the best data
AI capabilities in the industry
but that's not all coming from us
that needs to come from our products and
our partners so for example we do other
things like big lake and dataplex
trying to create really valuable Data
Insights for you so that you can use
those within your applications but in
addition to that
we worked very closely with spark we
have bigquery we have ledb something we
recently launched and postgres SQL the
whole idea is that we want you to be
able to use the data components that you
want in our Cloud to build Rich
data-filled applications and
we want to be able to bring one of our
true strengths which is Google AI not
just Cloud but all of Google's AI
capabilities to your applications
people ask me all the time what is the
future of an application look like in
your mind I tell them
deeply personal
intelligent data-driven applications
sometimes composed on the Fly
so the notion that we can construct and
deconstruct applications on the Fly is
coming I believe that is the future
so when we talk about AI we have things
like vertex AI Vision which allows you
gives you an entire environment
to be able to consume
streams of video in in and maintain
privacy
for the subjects
we have things like translation Hub
which allows you to translate across 135
different languages
easily and the number of uses that we're
seeing for this are tremendous
so I'm going to bring Abdul back up
because I was talking about it he's
going to show you a little bit and we
are going to stay on time you want to
come up and talk about and show them a
little bit about the data-driven
applications
sure thank you yep
thank you Matt
speaking of shoes unique no one else
have those
so our company symbol is an e-commerce
company which means they deal with a lot
of images and they ingest and process a
lot of images now when you are an
e-commerce company and you ingest images
one of the things you want to make sure
um is you want to make sure that these
images does not have private information
sensitive information or maybe either
other brands information so if somebody
takes pictures of my shoes and you put
them in a website maybe that website
will go live this is a Google logo we're
going to remove it right
and so one way we can do this is we can
take those images store them in Google
cloud storage and then we can create a
big lake table in bigquery
which will be based on the images from
Google cloud storage and what bigquery
will do it will create a table which
will track those images as you're
uploading new images into Google Cloud
Storage there will be some metadata
added to bigquery about those
then we can use we can train a machine
learning model to detect things of these
images uh using the vision AI API and
then after that what we can do also is
we can either use vertex AI pre-built
machine learning models to
um to detect things in images or we can
train and host our own model
and I'm I'm gonna attempt to do this I'm
not a machine learning neither data
engineer but I'll try to do this so if I
can get my demo
please back thank you so this is Google
Cloud Storage these are my images stored
in a bucket so you can see just like
random images
and here what I have done
is I have created a table in um in uh in
uh bigquery called raw images this table
is based on all the files that are
inside this Google Cloud Storage buckets
and basically what this will do it will
create a table for me
and this table will just have a bunch of
fields which tracks the content types of
the type of file the size uh etc etc and
then a bunch of metadata the value in
the metadata is actually the binary
information about the image itself
then what I can do with that is a bunch
of interesting things so one of them is
I can use
a pre-built machine learning model in
the vision EP in division AI API called
detect logos and what this model does it
will actually scan through the images
and detects if there are brand logos I
have already executed this query because
it takes a little bit of time and you
can see and the results it came up with
a bunch of
detections one of them for example is
here saying oh there is this image it
contains the Google logo right so it
detects an image that contains a logo
which is the Google one
so what this will do it will just give
you a notification mechanism so you can
detect images that contains Brands logo
now what you do with that depends on
what your what your um what's your goal
right so another way also of doing it is
you can use vertex AI to host your own
custom model so here I'm gonna create a
Vertex AI model based on an existing
machine learning model that I have
trained to detect other things like
sensitive information private
information Pia data or anything of that
nature and so once I have done that the
vertex AI model can be either queried
through SQL like this
or which basically is going to give us a
Json which we cannot really process or
you can actually use vertex AI endpoints
because one of the things the vertex AI
it gives you an HTTP endpoint and I can
use that endpoint to send some data to
it and it will return results telling me
Oh I detected this in the image I can
also use it to automatically remove
those or have human operators remove
them
and that concludes in My Demo I'll bring
back back Mattoon stage thank you very
much
we're in the home stretch
so first I want to thank you this was
the opening session the rest of the day
is going to be filled with bite-sized
deeply technical talks please pick the
sessions you want to go to and come talk
to the speakers when you get a chance if
you see us standing around one of the
hallways we'd love to hear about the
ideas that you've got I'd also like to
thank Julian and Abdel for taking us
deep into a couple areas in that and I
also want to remind everyone that the
reason why we are here is because of you
the reason why we build Google cloud is
actually because of Developers
our view is innovation happens elsewhere
it's the Innovation that you're all
creating that is most interesting to us
we're just creating the underlying
platform to enable you to go do that and
so to that end I also want to remind
everyone that we our free developer
program Google Cloud innovators please
come join if you want to spend time get
to know more like-minded developers like
yourselves it's a great way to keep in
touch with how we're doing how we're
engaging with the community and services
that we offer and being able to come to
events like this
I also want to quickly mention also what
Emily uh talked about was the the
opportunity with the Drone Racing League
it's a great opportunity to get down
into the data to go through some of the
challenges
um to to actually get it to actually use
the data in a really interesting way to
look at races
um potentially provide hints as to maybe
how Pilots can can get through courses
faster or better so really interesting
challenge please take a look
and then last what I want to do is offer
ask Emily to come back up on stage to
help close this session out I want to
thank all of you and I hope you enjoy
the rest of your day thank you very much
cool okay so thanks so much Matt uh
Julian and Abdel they clearly are
showing that we put developers in the
center of everything that we do so now
we're going to take a break we'll give
you guys some time give you folks some
time to go have some food have some
drink play some games and then we'll get
back into the content tracks so we're
going to start here officially at 11 30
and make sure to be here in the first 10
minutes to get that swag stamp and we're
going to hear five reasons why your Java
apps are better on Google Cloud so that
will be here on the main stage or you
can head upstairs where you can learn
how to write applications faster and
more securely with go that will be in
room Atlanta just one floor up so see
you all back here at 11 30 or upstairs
and enjoy ciao
[Applause]
[Music]
there's no place I'd rather be
ready
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we've heard of the world
[Applause]
welcome back to our energized developer
Community here in Munich and to those of
you watching online I hope you grabbed a
coffee and stretched your legs so for
our first tech track today we're going
to hear some reasons why your Java app
should find its home on Google cloud and
I'd like to welcome application
development customer engineer for
startups and scale-ups Dario benfi
[Music]
hello hi everyone how's it going welcome
to Google Cloud next here in Munich uh
it's so great to see so many of you
interested in Java especially since
there is also a goaling track going on
in the other room but it's good to see
so many Java developers
um
today I'm going to talk about five
reasons why your Java apps are better on
Google Cloud
and I know it's quite a bold statement
here I have 20 minutes to explain myself
so yeah I I get to it soon
my name is Dario Banfield I'm a customer
engineer here in Munich I actually live
100 meters from this venue
and this is not why I got invited to
talk here but the reason why I'm here
it's because I'm a Java developer myself
I've done Java on multiple layers of the
stack I've built a graphical user
applications with Java Swing
I recommend it I've used a lot of spring
I've done Android development kotlin
development so I've seen Java in a lot
of different forms and one thing I want
to talk about is how I think that Google
cloud is a great way to ask your job
application
so let me let me get to it let me get to
the reason so reason number one it's
about being able to deploy in seconds
so whenever you write an application you
don't want to spend a lot of time uh you
know dealing with servers jvm setting
your Java home you you want to just be
able to write your code and have it
running on Google Cloud very quickly
and with this you can do it very easily
with cloudrun on Google Cloud so Cloud
run is our fully managed container based
serverless platform
it lets you
build your code package it as a
container and deploy it on top of our
scalable infrastructure and it gives you
a lot of features out of the box like
Auto scaling scaling to zero
observability and so on
so it's a great fit for Java and also
other languages of course but it's a
it's a great way for you to really save
on you know
the deployment time that you would
otherwise be spending and the good thing
about Cloud run there was the quiz
question earlier it supports any
language you just need to package your
application as a container
and if you're using Java you don't even
need to write a container a Docker file
actually we support building from source
using uh under the HUD Cloud native
build packs with Builder packs you can
our software automatically detect the
language of your application and we'll
create a container for it so that you
don't even need to do that
let's let's see an example right so I
will walk you through a fictitious Java
application that we will create because
I don't have a demo but it's quite
simple so we can follow it like this
first of all we will curl from the
spring website the starter kit choosing
dependency web so this is just like a
simple Java API service that we want to
deploy
we don't load it on our local machine
and after that we unzip it and then we
will open the demo application Java so
the main class where our application
code will run
once we do that we just want to add a
sign of life right like a message from
saying hello from cloud run so in Spring
we just put an annotation a rest
controller we put a get mapping with a
root URL and then we are good to go
our simple application is ready we can
deploy it we can test it out
and when it comes to the deployment
phase I I'm a lazy developer and I
always ask myself what is the least
infrastructure management that meets my
needs
and I already said Cloud run is actually
a very good use case for this so we can
use cloud run
we go in the directory of our code and
all we need to do is run the command
gcloud run deploy
this command will interactively ask us
which apis we want to enable for example
artifact registry right like we want
this container stored in a container
registry and then it will ask us which
region we want to deploy it into
as of now we have 35 regions and just at
this conference we are announcing so
many more six five so
um you have like quite a lot of choice
in order to get your application very
close to your users
if you do need more customization you
can also put a cloud builder.yaml file
in your directory this will gives you
the configuration needed to for cloud
build our CI CD manage the platform and
for example is never a bad idea writing
some tests before deploying the code so
you can do this with Cloud build you can
add multiple steps and in Cloud build
each steps will be run by a separate
container so that you can choose very
specifically which uh dependency you
want to have in your container in order
to deploy your application so when you
deploy for example we can use the
container Cloud SDK which is provided by
us and lets you have like a gcloud
command line configured and ready to go
all right so this was a reason number
one ease of deployment
now let's let me get to reason number
two
after you deploy your application it's a
good practice to not have the entirety
of your traffic going to the new version
right away in case you have some issue I
don't know testing doesn't always catch
the issue so this practice is called the
canary deployments Canary rollouts and
it normally takes quite some effort to
build it yourself right like you need to
implement this logic and have this as
part of your cicd which is quite some
work and I don't want to do that
so we can use a cloud run a traffic
splitting feature for that
and for those of you who have seen it
you can go in the console you will have
your button managed traffic and from
there you will be able to select how
much traffic you want to each revision
a good practice is for example deploying
the first container with no traffic and
then scale it up and you can do this in
multiple multiple ways you can do it in
the console you can do it with a command
line you can do it uh probably like the
best will be to script this as part of
your CI CD so that's it's an automated
process ideally like with also some
automated monitoring in case your
production issues as some bugs so the
possibility are endless but the cool
thing is that it's really part of cloud
run and it's very simple to use
all right let me get to reason number
three so and this is really Java focused
right so
a couple of months ago we announced that
we have some optimization with Java
client libraries
so if you use for example uh bigquery or
if you use Pub sub or if you use any
Cloud native Google cloud service in
your application you probably have a
library for that
and our libraries now support natively
code compilation
for uh for uh for a native executable in
Java so that's a quite a good thing that
takes you that so you don't have to do
it yourself right you don't have to play
around with the configuration which is
also quite some work
I'll explain a bit more about that but
let me zoom out a bit let's talk about
Cloud run right uh
Cloud run as I said gives you Auto
scaling out of the box so you have here
three containers right your application
is getting a lot of traffic so Cloud run
started multiple distances of the
service
what happens that if the traffic goes
down Cloud run will also scale down
until you get to zero no more containers
and this is normally quite good for you
because you're actually not paying for
this container right so scaling to zero
is actually a very useful feature
depending on the application you have
the problem is that whenever you will
get the first request you will have
what's called in cloud computing as a
cold start so cold start me are is the
delay that it takes from cloud run to
start your container from a state where
there is no containers
and your users can experience that and
of course it can be annoying or
depending on your application it can
become a problem
so how do we solve that there is
a couple of ways the simplest one is to
use in Cloud run the concept of minimum
instances
with minimum instances you say that I
want this amount of container to be
running always at the same time
so that you completely avoid the problem
of cold start the container will be
always running but you also lose the
advantage that we discussed that you are
going to be paying for this container
actually the price is a bit lower so if
you check on the pricing page you can
learn about it but still you're paying
the right and we don't want that
and the second way to do it is Java
native compilation
this became a really popular a couple of
years ago with grad VM I'm sure many of
you already play with that and the
difference is quite significant for
cloud native application especially for
containerized workloads that run
kubernetes or a serverless platform
let's see an example right I made a with
the same service I downloaded earlier I
made an example between a native
application which will have a startup
startup time of around 486 millisecond
and your traditional job application
where the startup time will be around
seven seconds so this is almost like one
order of magnitude more and yeah it's
it's quite relevant
native compilation has other benefits
also there is not only startup time it's
also about memory utilization Peak
Performance
and it also has just some drawbacks but
depending on your use case it can be a
great uh tool to use and let me quickly
explain the difference
between just in time compilation which
we use in your traditional Java
application so you write your Java code
it gets compiled to bytecode and then
this bytecode is translated to machine
code Just In Time by the Java virtual
machine
when you use ahead of time compilation
this is done ahead of time this is done
before so the this the machine code will
be generated and will be run directly on
the architecture where you are deploying
to
um and uh yeah as I said for cloud
native workloads it can be really
Adventures advantages
so going back to the initial
announcement uh we all of our libraries
supported Java native complete
compilation and yeah I invite you to try
this out and in your application and I'm
also going to give you a couple of
concrete tips on how to do that
um if you're used for you're using for
example spring native which is probably
like the most popular Java framework I
would say you can further improve the
performance by optimizing the classes
that get loaded in the class path as
startup time so for example we have a
spring accept expression language we
have XML if you don't need them you can
use this configuration to remove them
you can also use a spring native class
initialization so for example you can
say which classes should be initialized
at build time versus runtime and I could
take talk for hours here because Java
typically initializes classes at runtime
and this is as like a of course like a
latency
tall on your application
so with this Flex you can reduce that
it's not super simple right like you
need to read a bit which classes can be
initialized at real time because it's
not valid for all type of classes they
need to be safe classes but it's also
like another performance Improvement
that you can Leverage
and then lastly it's a native quick
build mode so if you ever built a Java
native application and you don't have a
powerful computer you know the pain it
will start flying out of your room
so with Native quick build mode you can
actually reduce the time it takes to
compile your Java application you just
pass the minus 0b flag
and the the the timer will be quite
significant so this is the time it takes
for a normal compilation right so 63
seconds four gigabyte of memory and we
take quick build mode it's going to be
42 seconds and less than half the memory
so it's pretty good especially if you
build hundreds of containers per day
all right let me go to number four it's
about security we talked already a lot
about that about uh you know salsa which
is not the Mexican Dipa but it stands
for supply chain levels for software
artifacts
it's a security framework that gives you
some prescriptive measures on how to
secure your cicd pipeline and this
became quite relevant after the
solarwinds heck a couple of years ago
where the cicd was compromised and some
malicious code was deployed to multiple
environments
so if you want to enable sign builds you
can use binary authorization this makes
sure that only code that gets built by
your CI CD pipeline is allowed to be
deployed in cloudron
let's see how it looks so if you go on
cloud run you can go to your services
and you can go on the details page in
the console for example
from there you will see that there is a
binary authorization flag so you can
enable it
and once you enable it you have to
configure a policy which which you can
do by clicking the button or scripting
it
once you do that you will see that there
is a summer testers
testers are entities which are allowed
to sign a given build and this build
will be cryptographically signed right
so in our policy we will click edit and
we will say that
only a specific a tester like built by
Cloud build in this case is Maya tester
will be allowed to deploy on cloud run
so you just click the checkbox required
attestation and from now on no other
image which is not built by Cloud build
will be allowed to be deployed so it's
pretty neat so you you know for sure
that no one can just deploy an image
from the docker registry without
approval and you can make sure that your
CI CD becomes the central place where
security is enforced for example you
create some Security checks you create
some building ability scanning we talked
about today about open source Library
scanning so this is a great place to do
it and it's a great way to enforce it
all right so this was my reason number
four so now comes to the last reason
which is actually an announcement we are
making at next
and the announcement is that Google
Cloud joined the eclipse adoptium
working group
eclipse adoptum is a consortiums of java
leaders which is uh the entity behind
the temuri build of java
has been become really popular in the
past years it's one of the mostly most
used jdk and it has like the highest
standards of uh security of
compatibility so from now on uh or like
not now on but very soon you will be
able to use the tamuri build in all of
our serverless products so including for
example Cloud functions app engine so it
will be the jdk behind the your Java
application so we are looking forward
for you to try this out
and yeah so let me recap I covered a lot
of ground so five reasons
easy deployments and Payless with Cloud
run salsa compliant uh out of the box a
lot of features
one of these is of course Advanced
deployment patterns using uh traffic
splitting using this concept of canary
rollouts
you get native image support for your
Java client libraries so
go on and try building your job
applications to native code
and you get security from the CI CD
using signed bills to production using
very soon the tamarina jdk into your
application
all right so that was it I hope I could
teach you something new and I hope you
enjoy the rest of the session today
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay everybody the next session is
kubernetes and Java fast development
workflow in ballroom and
state-of-the-art neural networks neural
architecture search in the Room Atlanta
at 12 o'clock
[Music]
we're together we're so alive yet
together with someone alive
[Music]
forever
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
song
[Music]
down I think we better do it like we're
doing it now it's been a long time
[Applause]
[Music]
Let's Get Down
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
some cars
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
we are moving right along so welcome
back for the next tech track those of
you here in real life and all of you
watching online
so now that the Java audience is warmed
up let's continue with Community member
extraordinaire and back-end engineer at
Spotify Muhammad abelite showing us how
to build a fast workflow with kubernetes
and Java welcome Muhammad
[Music]
hello everyone
[Applause]
um great Java content at the conference
today can I get my slides back here can
you switch to my laptop oh
okay give me a minute to switch to the
slides
mirror display should be fine now
yes fantastic ah sorry for the small uh
issue so everyone I am Mohammed I was a
I work as a back-end engineer at Spotify
and also I'm Cloud Google Cloud
innovator champion and today I'm going
to highlight some great open source
projects by Google Cloud team thank you
for that that makes working with Java
and kubernetes especially GK a lot more
fun and speed up our development
workflow
so when we talk about
when we talk about developer workflow
and some We call we call it also the
inner development workflow we talk about
four major steps the first one in is
introducing business changes making new
feature introducing new feature fixing a
bug or actually just improving the user
experience right we call that the code
uh phase and then once we are happy with
our changes we compile the code we build
it in order to generate an artifact that
could be in a traditional Java
application a jar or air whatever Java
artifacts you have or you can build
actually that container image
once we build our artifact we deploy it
either to a traditional Java application
server or it could be to the cloud in a
kubernetes or whatever your container
orchestration tool and finally we do
some primitive testing now I'm not
talking about integration test unit
tests I'm just talking you opening the
browser or whatever API tool you want to
have and testing actually your changes
so this is actually the four major
phases of our development workflow right
however when you move it to Containers
into the cloud containers are great
right they become the executables of the
cloud and they change the way we develop
architecture and deploy our containers
they have a lot of goodness we heard for
the past few years a lot of goodness
about containers a lot of companies
bridge and how awesome they are right
however when it comes to development
they didn't make actually the
development experience fun they bring
this additional layer of abstraction
that made the developer experience a
little bit a little bit slow now let's
take this example
those are the steps that are typical a
developer will follow in order to deploy
its changes like we start with building
our Java artifact then uh building our
image using Docker build Command right
then we tag that push it God I'm getting
I'm not even halfway through I'm tired
and then we change our manifest uh
deploy it using Cube uh Cube Cube CTR
apply we connect to our cluster check if
the ports are healthy check in the locks
and finally checking up testing our
changes ah I made it
so if we want to
decompose and categorize those all steps
we can categorize them into four five
major categories actually the first one
is the belt so we built our artifact and
generates our uh
container jar whatever and then we'll
continue sorry here we in the
containerized phase we generate our
container image and there we we push it
to our remote registry
and then we deploy it in our favorite
container orchestration tool and then we
connect to that cluster to check if
everything is working right however we
as developers we don't care about all
the steps right we only care about
introducing changes making changes and
checking that the code we launch Works
according to expectation it does the job
that we needed to do and
in 2014 a dear friend which is James
Ward which is La cotton PM wrote that
long development and validation Cycles
really sucks
so when a developer spend a lot of time
waiting for the changes waiting to see
and test their changes actually their
productivity will act eventually plunge
and it will affect the business because
a slow developer means that the whole
team would be slow to deliver a feature
and it will also mean that the other
teams that depend on your team will
actually get slow so the whole business
becomes you get slower losing billions
of dollars just for fast of a broken
developer experience if I might say
so this has nothing to do with my
presentation I'm just like trying to
look Smart in front of a smart audience
but that's only to say that uh we need
to analyze the five steps and try if we
can automate them optimize them in order
to make the developer experience working
with containers and in this case Java
and some of the tools apply to other
languages but I'll be focusing on Java
in this case
and
analyzing the two first steps which is
the build and continue rise there are
some issues and some
um
things that we can improve uh regarding
uh the way we build our containers
images right
starting with the builds take longer
when we build our container our
artifacts and containers compared to
when we build them locally with our
favorite build tools like Maven or
Gradle right whatever we do whatever we
optimize the building containers take
longer compared to building our Java
artifact directly
with the rise to of cloud native and the
move to Fat jars by all the Java
Frameworks Springwood micronauts
quarkers we started building the fat
jars now fat jars are great if you're
running them directly however they break
the caching optimizations of Docker and
containers in general since each time
you change a tiny little bit of your
code you are building a new fat jar and
that means and you hash ID of your image
layer and that needs a slow push process
and slow pull and deploy process as well
there are some limitations with the
docker belt comment like sequential
execution it cannot execute comments in
parallel there are some caching issues
and especially if you are mounting
folders there are some each pollutes
your current file system with root files
no caching issues for security reasons
obviously
and uh no volume sorry and finally there
are no safe way to access in uh private
repositories such as get or history now
to be completely transparent here those
issues are some of them are solved with
buildkit so if you are not using build
kit yet try to enable it in your Docker
desktop
and finally Docker CLI is great is it
has a lot of options to enable you to do
magic things however it's become
overloaded over the year with more
features that are necessarily developed
or focused it has features for Docker
swarm always using Docker smart whatever
and a couple of years back it has like
some features for Docker ee right so
it's maybe not the right tool for the
job
and we as Java developers are familiar
with the standardized artifact like we
are familiar with building our code and
generating a jar a war and air whatever
and the ideal scenario for us would be
to use the same old build tools Maven
and Gradle and generate the new Unity of
deployment of the cloud which is
containers and thanks to the Google
Cloud Engineers we have such tool it's
called Google Jet and it stands for Java
image Builder
so Java image Builder is actually a pure
Java plugin so if you want to improve
something fix something you can actually
just contribute to the code is open
source it uses both Maven and Gradle and
my favorite part is actually it's demos
meaning that you don't need to have a
Docker this demon and solid on your
machine and it is fast specially under
producible builds and it's reproducible
and what jib does is basically similar
to what's in this Docker file so jib
since it's a Java plugin it splits your
application into multiple layers so it
benefits from the caching mechanism of
containers and you put the files that
are less likely to change on the top
which are the your dependencies your
resources and the files are more likely
to change on the bottom which are our
classifieds and that helps if you change
it only the class files only one layer
will get changed rather than the whole
uh application basically so that's why
the reason why it's fast especially in
reproducible bits
and
jip is really customizable really
configurable you can configure anything
you want your base image
um it I forgot to mention that it
generates oci compatible formats so
that's why you don't need to have a
Docker Daemon it has three major faces
or three major goals the first one is J
belt or Maven J build if you want to it
basically Builds an image and push it to
our remote registry
if you want to Cache your image locally
in your Docker demon you can use Docker
build and if you would generate a tarp a
chart file then you can do that with
buildtar
and the default base image in jib it
uses destroys Java and this is Java is a
part of a Google
Cloud project as well called a destroys
container images now the Solace
container images aims to create
Contender images that are contains only
your application and its runtime
dependencies restricting what's inside
your application or your container to
exactly what your application need to
perform its function
now that is great for two reasons from a
security point of view since you have
only what you need during runtime and
from a size point of view which means
that you will have faster push and you
will have have faster pull and deploy as
well
and so with jib we hopefully managed to
reduce the build and continuous time
how about deployment time can we
automate the other steps which is like
tagging our images pushing it and
deploying a Java cluster and another
cool open source projects from the
Google Cloud Engineers called scaffold
super easy it's basically a command line
tool it's a common CLI that does a lot
of things it reminds the build of your
container pushing it deploying it and
entailing the logs and even does a port
forwarding if you want to have that now
you can use scaffold on the favorite CI
tool and save it into your favorite
style side tool so you have a consistent
experience between the development and
CI CD but we are going to focus on the
development uh part in this talk
so this is what basic was scaffold
basically does does a lot of things it
sync the files it's uh build your
control the container image for you it
tagged different different technique
strategies it tests it and here you can
either use another cool project open
source container structure tests that
enable you to test the structure of your
container image and verify its
compliance or you can Define your Custom
Custom text similar to what we do with
Maven tests or gradual tests or whatever
and it enables you to tag your artifacts
and then generate the Manifest
so if you are using customize or hell it
helps to generate the final manifest
before deploying them and then once you
deployed it tail the logs and gather
them giving you a great overview of how
your application is doing so we can have
a quick feedback loop and for and with
that I'm going to demo some of scaffold
and
features so before going here I have
first a very small spring boot
application that is basically have one
endpoint
which is a Hello uh application that
whenever is it visible in the back cool
so it's a basically one endpoint that
Sprints an event Stream So each one
second and it says hello words
so I have scaffold already configured
and they have the configuration file
here so as everything in Cloud native
word it's a yaml file you need to live
with it and I defined it multiple steps
so the first one is the build step and
I'm basically using jib and as you can
see in my pump file I have the zip
plugin already here the latest version I
hope
and then for the test I'm using the
structured tests
um so as I mentioned you can use the
structure test which is another cool
project from the Google Cloud team and
it's basically verified the structure
and the compliance of your application
so here I'm verifying the Java version
of that container that is Java 17 the
user ID and I'm checking that the layers
the files that jib creates are there
already so quick win
um I'm also doing some port forwarding
from 8080 the default Port of spring
boot to Port 900 I'm deploying using
Cube CDL and if I want to start scaffold
I only have to in develop in development
mode I have to do scaffold Dev and what
it basically does it will start to get
if I have the image locally it would
start to pull it up otherwise it will
build a new one
push it to the container image and
deploy it using Cube CDL as I've
mentioned it here and it will try to
pull the logs and deploy the application
now this is taking more time than
expected
but it's uh it's getting there so it's
running to tests and the tests are
failing aha
the why do we need to do to Dr demon
gosh this is not good
I need to log in okay open docker
Docker trying to uh Kill My Demo
thanks docker
let's try now
okay just run in yes all passed perfect
fantastic now I'm trying to deploy my
image
deployment is already done and you can
see here it's already Port forwarded to
Port 9000 and if I'm lucky you can see
the hello world application up and
running right and now what happened if I
want to introduce some changes and
so this year I want to Google Cloud next
the moment I would next the moment I hit
Ctrl save you would see here that it
will redo the same process without me
doing anything it will try to
build a new image run to chess to make
sure that everything is fine and then
deploy it
and when port forward and then I will
see my application in the logs that my
application is started now if I go back
and refresh
I would get the Google Cloud Nest
application up and running and once I
hit Ctrl C to exit my scaffold Dev mode
you will see that the application it
will basically try to clean up your
remote cluster removing all kubernetes
objects there now this is a very simple
application and you may see that you may
say that yeah our production application
are more complex than that so I have I
sealed another production similar
application which is a bit store so it's
using a
it's using actually macronaut and they
have it deployed in gke cluster already
so it has a micro service application
with a couple of uh with a couple of
databases so it had multiple
applications a front-end application
using react and it's all automated using
scaffold so I have the front-end
application using react using the sync
file I'm going to demo that in a minute
and I have other application that's
using micronauts framework both written
in groovy and Java and different other
Java languages
so uh I cheated a little bit so
application is already up and running
and if I am lucky I would see that the
application is up yes so this is my
application
and I mentioned the sinking feature of
uh scaffold right so I have the home.js
application which is the front
um the front end or the home page of my
custom application what happen if
I changed it a bit
next though the moment I hit Ctrl save I
don't no longer need to build an
application since since it's a react
application it's basically sync defies
directly to my remote cluster without
building the image as it's mentioned uh
sorry not this one probably uh it's this
one yes sync in my application so if I
go back to my application it says I'm
activating the hot reload mode in my
react application it instantly picked
actually my application without needing
me to do anything
um so this was a quick demo of scaffold
uh goodness
so we managed to shorten the steps from
five to one maybe or two we need to do
some configuration with Jep if you're a
Java developer uh and basically running
scaffold Dev in your uh config in your
application to have a decent and a more
uh enjoyable developer experience
now
to files and I already touch it upon
this during the demo yaml files
uh I have a problem with the ammos but
I'm not going to start the discussion
now but Yammer files especially if
you're working in the cloud native world
are really we end up managing a lot of
yaml files per environment per version
it adds a lot of complexity
so we need a way to customize it and
you're probably already doing that
and either we have basically a couple of
options either we start using hell and
Helm follows a configuration over values
kind of uh kind of solution and so you
have basically uh the base or the
configuration you define variables in
your uh kubernetes manifest and you
define the values of the of those
variables depending of the on the
version and also the environment that
you want to run your application uh into
Helm three solve it a lot of problems
and a lot of pains with Helm since it
becomes now a client focused uh version
previously it was a client server and
you need to have teller or whatever is
called on your kubernetes cluster now
it's much more lightweight and it does
all its magic in the client side
and my favorite tool is actually
customize so customize as the name uh
suggests is basically a solution to
customize your application and it follow
a different approach it's basically
enable you to defer to define a skeleton
which is the shared manifest of all your
versions and all your environments
and we Define additional yamos per
environments on per version right and
what it does is basically what's in this
slide so we Define our skeleton our base
image our base configuration file and we
Define the changes and updates that we
want to do and the generated version
will be basically the merge of those two
and we end up with a much structured
yaml file that enable us to basically
Define and deploy your application per
version and per environment
so this is basically it uh scaffold is a
great tool that we customizable and
extendable with different uh
environments for building you could use
jib you could use Docker build you could
use build packs whatever you want uh
there are different testing strategies
different tagging strategies and
different way to deploy your
applications and if you want you can
make your own uh and build your own as
well and shove it in into scaffold so
with that I want to thank you and the
demo of today is already on GitHub open
source and you have any question be
happy to take them
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hi I'm Shaquille O'Neal and I'm the
founder of big chicken
[Music]
big chicken is Shaquille O'Neal's
emerging fast casual restaurant chain
that focuses on big fun big flavor and
big food when you're trying to build the
national chain communication is so
critical to do that you need a great
partner we're really lucky that partner
is Google workspace you know Josh every
time he does a presentation he just
loves Google's life as the person
responsible for our marketing probably
the best at Google Slides
this presentations is like I'm at a
movie sometime I'm just sitting there
going
I've got some great new chicken
sandwiches for you to try brand new
recipes
isn't there something important we're
supposed to be talking about good recipe
development comes with collaboration
using docs in Google workspace gives us
the tools we need to collaborate
together
Shaquille's life gets crazy busy as does
our entire board you want to talk to me
make sure you put on my Google Calendar
Google Calendar is my girlfriend
don't know anything I'm doing unless I
talk to my woman
Google workspace productivity and
collaboration tools for all the ways you
work
[Music]
Google's infrastructure power services
for billions of people and then Google
Cloud takes those lessons from running
these services in order to deliver an
Innovative and easy to use cloud
infrastructure today Google Cloud helps
users automate the life cycle of their
workloads in the future we'll use AI to
understand workload patterns and do this
automatically intelligently optimizing
for higher performance with lower
latency cost and power consumption
today we optimize our infrastructure for
AIML and your data ensuring that it is
accessible anywhere but we're not
stopping there triplets are a new design
and Manufacturing process that brings
open source agility to the world of
silicon by using a building block
approach Gaston chips for a vast range
of configurations sustainability is
important to us because our planet
depends on it and we will operate on 24
7 carbon free energy by 2030. every
email you send through Gmail or every
question you ask search and every
virtual machine you spin up across our
Cloud will be supplied by carbon free
energy every hour of every day we are
Reinventing infrastructure where AI
based automation will recommend the most
efficient design for your workloads
based on your usage and we'll run them
on Google's unique infrastructure
optimize specifically for you all of
this delivered on the cleanest cloud in
the world this is our next we can't wait
to see what you do with it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so I'm standing backstage at the Google
clouds HQ we're literally seconds away
from kicking off the keynote for
developer
I am so excited to share our predictions
are you ready
let's do this
hello everyone please welcome Google
developers vice president Janine Banks
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome to next 22.
I'm Janine Banks and I lead developer
products and community at Google my team
and I love empowering developers to
build Innovations for the future
which leads me to the theme of Nexus
year
today meet tomorrow
to tell you a little more about how we
think about tomorrow my friends and I at
Google Cloud will share top technology
predictions for where we believe the
cloud is headed over the next three
years
each one of us will share the one
prediction We Believe will be true by
the end of 2025.
and we love to hear what predictions you
all come up with too
you can do that by responding to our
original video or creating your own
video on YouTube shoots shorts or any
other social video platform
just use the hashtag Google Cloud
predictions and tell us all about it
but before we get into all of that I
want to talk about our developer
Community for a minute
I get most excited about the incredible
ideas and new products coming from our
community as well as the opportunity we
have to help developers learn grow and
build powerful systems and engaging
experiences
Google's developer Community is
inclusive
one where Cloud developers at every
level of expertise are welcome while
being challenged at the same time
and being part of Google's developer
Community creates true economic impact
because Google Cloud certified
professionals are some of the highest
paid in the industry
this same Cloud developer Community
Fosters the creators and by that I'm
talking about the students the career
switchers and anyone else hoping to
become a developer who's encouraged and
supported to bring their Creations to
life
like we saw with our partner in Brazil
Soul code Academy and one of our newest
professional data Engineers Patricia
take a look
is
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is why I'm excited to come to work
every single day and the potential of
what we can build together with all of
you
speaking of exciting we recently
announced a new partnership with the
Drone Racing League we built new
immersive learning experiences with DRL
that will blow your mind
you can participate in the Google Cloud
challenge where you can get Hands-On
with drl's race data and Google cloud
services
You can predict race outcomes give
performance tips to DRL Pilots to help
them smoke their competitors and learn
all at the same time
and you even get to compete for a chance
to win a trip to the season finale of
the League's World Championship
you can get started with the challenge
right now
we look forward to seeing what you'll
build next as we fly into the future of
clouds together
do you see what I did just there fly
drones okay okay
are you ready
let's go
[Music]
my prediction is by the end of 2025
developers will start with with neural
inclusive design we'll see a 5x growth
in user adoption in their first two
years in production
according to the National Institutes of
Health up to 20 percent of the world's
population is neurodistinct
with the other 80 being neurotypical
these two groups make up what is called
neural diversity
and neurodiversity describes the ways
people experience interpret and process
the world around them whether in school
at work or through social relationships
and here at Google we believe the world
and our workplace needs all types of
thinkers
what do you think about that Jim that's
right one in five of us here are Nero
distinct but what is Nero inclusive
design
ER occlusive design is designed for
cognitive and sensory accessibility
one of the things that makes
participation in meetings accessible to
me is the raise hand function it allows
me to pause the Cadence of the meeting
to provide an opportunity to share my
thoughts
then we realized that this made meetings
better for everyone it created more
structure for everybody which enabled
visibility and broader range of ideas
so narrow inclusive design starts with
raising accessibility for neurodistinct
people like myself
everyone benefits
good design is already neuro inclusive
when implemented properly as an example
When developing interactive and visual
features we need to consider how noise
vibrations or pop-ups show up in design
because it creates sensory stimulation
that leads to distraction
design principles can be made Nero
inclusive when you plan thoughtfully for
balance proportion Unity light color
space and patterns and here are some
tips for developers number one
designed with Simplicity and clarity
number two remove distractions or extra
visualizations like pop-up Windows three
avoid really bright colors are too much
of a single color
four
stick with the predictable and intuitive
user flow
five
be thoughtful about the vibe you are
setting do you need music or sounds to
set the tone or is that just an extra
element that can create distraction
and finally six
stay away from pressure points requiring
a quick reaction from the users this can
add unnecessary pressure
back to you Janine
thanks Jim this upfront design
thoughtfulness is just so important how
often have any of you been pressured to
ship something but you knew you could
have improved the user experience with
just a little more time
at Google we feel that ideation user
research testing and marketing
disproportionately helped teams launch
more inclusive products faster
while these are standard practices in
software development where we made a
conscious decision to have all types of
thinkers included across these phases
our eyes open in so many new ways to be
more inclusive
for example closed captioning in Google
meet helps all of us process information
better visually it also helps people
participating in meetings where
different languages use
when you build simple clear experiences
with fewer distractions your products
will inherently Drive greater user
adoption in fact what did I say
I predict 5x more in your first two
years in production
this is because developers like us will
have built belonging directly into our
products
so that's my prediction now I'm going to
pass the mic to some of my friends here
at Google Cloud to share their
predictions thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Eric Brewer and my prediction
is that by the end of 2025 four out of
five Enterprise developers will use some
form of curated open source
now you're probably wondering what is
curated open source
curated open source is just open source
as you know it but with a layer of
accountability what I mean by that is
curated open source comes with support
for Developers
and the curator in this case will focus
on not just finding vulnerabilities but
helping to fix them too they'll update
all dependencies and track new ones
with curated open source the curators
will build in automation for testing may
even offer response-based slas
and here's why this is so important for
the community
open source is everywhere
it helps power our electrical grids
Water Supplies oil pipelines it's
fundamental to all clouds
most Nations and even widely used in
proprietary software
open source is public infrastructure and
it's essential part of our everyday
lives
so now what
open source is here to stay with
everything in Powers is vulnerable
the incidents are real and they are
costly
that's why governments are stepping in
with regulations like federamp and
executive orders to combat cyber
security
regulations like these are super
important and show us just How Deeply
security vulnerabilities impact Our
Lives
but in fact these regulations are
exactly why we need curation
curated open source enables you to
depend on the open source beyond the as
is approach we use today
we believe in this philosophy so much
that we are already working on it
to help you build to care apps faster
we're releasing software delivery Shield
this is a fully managed security
solution that protects your software
supply chain from source to deployment
and as part of SDS we have our initial
curated open search example called
assured OSS
this service curates open source
packages used by Google and makes it
available to you our Cloud Developers
Google will scan analyze and fuzz test
more than 250 Java and python packages
for security vulnerabilities on your
behalf and we'll update them as needed
so don't believe me that developers use
some form of curation
how about this let us show you what
we're going doing at Google to make this
reality hi Aja hey Eric so let's
actually see what the software delivery
life cycle looks like if you use
software delivery Shield to enforce
responsible use in open source through
policy
so we're going to start with Cloud
workstations a complete development
environment in the cloud
Cloud workstations is highly
customizable and the version I'm showing
today has all the tools and compilers
and everything I need including the
brand new source protect extension
actually right here you can see that
Source protect has flagged a dependency
with a known vulnerability
I can fix this right now on my
workstation before anything is ever
checked in
now Cloud workstation is going to
automatically detect those changes and
it's going to redeploy my app on my
workstations as needed this shortens my
Dev Loop and makes me more productive
so when I push my changes because I'm
happy with them Cloud build is going to
run continuous integration against our
code base
here you can see a cloud build build
report and you can see that we provide
salsa level 3 compliant build prominence
Cloud build also scans for
vulnerabilities
and here we can see a list of
vulnerabilities including details on
many of them and in some cases even the
fix that we need to make to address it
now it happens to be that the image that
Eric and I are working with today has
several external open source
dependencies for example spring boot
starter
in general pulling these directly from
the internet could pose some risk
fortunately that dependency and many
others are in the assured OSS portfolio
so that I can use a version of that
dependency that's been vetted by Google
which is what you've been telling us
about this is exactly the point you
don't have to worry about these
dependencies because they are already
vetted for you
and so now that I know that I don't have
to worry as much about these
dependencies it's time to push the code
to prod so let's actually look at a
delivery pipeline
here's a cloud deploy delivery pipeline
super simple one we've just got a Dev
and a test environment and when I'm
happy with my code and depth I can
promote it to fraud
and we can deploy to gke
so while that's deploying
let's look at one last thing
here's the new gke security posture page
here I can see security concerns on both
the cluster and workload level
I can dig into any concerns if I need to
including seeing recommended actions to
take to mitigate any issues that were
identified
so that's the dev to prod tour of
software delivery Shield so you can see
how it helps you use open source
responsibly all the way from the when
you start writing code to when it's
released into production that was great
thank you Aja
we love co-creating
we just want to make sure there's an
added layer of accountability to better
support you and the apps you build
is why we believe that four out of five
Enterprise developers will use some form
of curated open source thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
first off it is so nice to see everyone
here in the room give it up for being
back in in person right
all right so hello everyone my name is
Iman ganizada and my prediction is that
by the end of 2025 90 of security
operations workflows will be automated
and managed as code
okay so secops teams are struggling to
keep up with the attackers we all know
this right there's there's too much data
complex technology environments and
there's more adversaries now more than
ever I mean every day on the news we
hear about a new 18 year old that has
breached a company right
so so let's go ahead and let's pair this
with the detection and response workflow
which is notoriously centered around
toil and it requires a linear growth in
people to keep up with the volume of
threats
but we all know we can just hire a bunch
more people right like every ciso has a
billion dollars in their bank and you
know they're just waiting to hire 700
000 people
so this inefficient workflow has
basically created the cyber security
Talent shortage there's over 700 000
unfilled cyber jobs and these jobs
they're they're high stress they're
overloaded with toil-based work and a
lot of folks are quite frankly just
burnt out so there's just no way that
this issue is going to get solved if we
keep doing things the way that we're
doing them today
so the scale security across Cloud we're
going to make security more agile and
accessible to everyone through code
here's how
so our autonomic security operations
framework is designed to help you take
advantage of our API first approach with
Chronicle security operations and other
tools including many of those tools that
are within our new mandian portfolio
this shift in our new framework takes
traditional assembly line security
operations workflows into a codified
continuous feedback model we call
continuous detection continuous response
or cdcr for short
you can imagine it's it's kind of like
cicd but but for threat management
we've seen customers like BBVA and NCR
and as well as our mssp partners like
cideris use our tools to build
continuous detection response workflows
that scale across billions of alerts
and so earlier this year we actually
partnered with miter Ingenuity with
cideris and others to launch community
security Analytics
CSA is an open source repo that we
created to Foster Community
collaboration on developing security
analytics for your cloud workloads
these analytics can be deployed as code
to complement the native detection
capabilities in chronicle and other
Google Cloud tools
so it's it's kind of like having a team
of devs collaborating on your detection
rules
so I'll show you how to deploy these
rules but first let's actually dive into
an example okay
let's just say that there's a user
outside of your devops team that gets
access to impersonate a highly
privileged Production Service account
that probably wouldn't be good right
so yeah so to rule 2.20 analyzes your
admin activity logs for permission
grants on service accounts
and for this next part we went ahead and
pre-recorded this because we wanted to
save time and also I don't want to have
you watch me fumble over my keys and
take down Us East or something
so first we're starting in the terminal
and we've already cloned a private repo
here
now we're going to go ahead and open up
that URL rule and we can add parameters
to fine-tune the world our needs so in
case you haven't noticed Chronicles URL
syntax is very very very simple compared
to other detection languages
now we're going to go ahead and commit
and push our changes and we already have
a GitHub action set up to Auto deploy
these rules into our Chronicle instance
and by the way Chrono can be deployed as
code and it can scale across petabytes
of data without needing infrastructure
or human involvement I mean it's it's as
Cloud native as they come
okay so we're going to Pivot into our
Chronicle instance we're going to
refresh and let's see voila okay boom so
there's our new rule and from this point
on it's going to start alerting when
this malicious activity is identified
we can also run a retro hunt which
essentially takes this Rule and it runs
it against all of our historical data
and Chronicle to see if there's an alert
that we missed and we've done retro
hunts with customers that have taken
seconds or minutes that may have taken
them hours or days with their existing
tools I mean it's like it's Uber fast
we can also use Chronicle soar to create
a an automation Playbook basically to
figure out how to respond to this type
of alert
and we also have Autumn we also have
apis to automate this entire thing from
ingest to analytics to response
so the moral of the story is what
um none of us want to end up on the news
right
so so in order to make this 90
prediction a reality security analysts
are going to have to work a lot more
like devs so they can free up time to
focus on the most important threats to
their organizations so you'll need to
implement modern developer friendly
workflows like cdcr across your
detection and response practice and what
I've shown you today is how we're making
it possible for you to do so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hi my name is Camilia aryafar and my
prediction is by the end of 2025 AI is
going to be the primary driver for
moving to a four day work week
foreign
so what does this mean to you and me a
three-day weekend
well what it actually means is being
able to comfortably complete five days
worth of work in four days or even less
with efficiencies gained through AI
Enterprise use of AI alone exploded over
the past few years touching all aspects
of business one of the greatest reasons
behind this is ai's huge potential to
increase employee productivity
you have told us how excited you are to
work with Google Cloud because we make
all of the AI research AI models and ml
toolkits from Google available to you as
Enterprise grade products and solutions
like vertex AI
since its launch vertex AI has helped
data scientists ship ml models faster
into production by automating routine
tasks like Model Management monitoring
and versioning
with vertex AI data scientists can now
build and train ml models five times
faster meaning increased time for
experimentation reduce custom coding and
the ability to move more ml models into
production
today with the announcement of vertex AI
Vision we are taking this a step further
and providing you with a fully managed
development environment for creating
computer vision applications
in the general keynote with a smart City
use case my colleague Jun Yang discussed
how you can use vertex AI Vision to
reduce the time required to build and
deploy computer vision applications from
weeks to hours
now let's dive into three areas that I
as a developer am most excited about
when it comes to vertex AI vision
the ability to use your own custom
models
integration with bigquery
and developing external applications
with sdks
let's see how
first in the Smart City example we used
a pre-built occupancy analytics model to
detect and count Vehicles now if I want
to do the same thing for bicycles I can
use a custom bicycle detection model in
vertex Ai and easily imported into my
computer vision application
basically if the model Works in vertex
AI then it will also work in vertex AI
vision
second I want to use the power of
bigquery to combine video annotations
with other information in my data
warehouse
by the way I can also store annotations
in the included Vision Warehouse feature
to easily search for insights across my
video
by using vertex AI Vision together with
bigquery I can correlate traffic
patterns with weather patterns or even
make a forecast with bigquery ml to
predict future traffic patterns
finally I can use the SDK to access
process video data and annotations and
hook into a live stream of vehicle
accounts to power other applications or
dashboards
it's that simple and it can be applied
to one video stream or even hundreds of
video streams
this level of flexibility and
scalability is unique to Google cloud
and that's how we help you reduce the
development time for computer vision
applications from weeks to hours
not just with vertex AI Vision but all
of Google Cloud's AI products are built
to help you be more productive and
Delight your customers
for example using contact center Ai call
center teams can manage up to 28 more
conversations concurrently
product a lot more productivity
with translation Hub localization teams
can translate documents into 135
languages in a matter of seconds which
means time saved for other efforts and a
more inclusive workplace
similarly with Google Cloud's
recommendations AI merchandising and
e-commerce teams can now Drive 40 more
customer conversions
there's a lot more happy customers and a
happy sales seem to
when you put together all of these
productivity gains powered by AI across
the organization a four day work week is
a very distinct possibility
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Irina Farooq and my prediction is
that by the end of 2025 90 of data will
be actionable in real time using ml
this prediction and that's
understandable
survey found that only one third of all
companies are able to realize tangible
value from their data
and we continue to hear that many of you
are trying to fix that by taking on the
operational burden of managing data
infrastructure moving data around and
duplicating data to make it available to
the right users in the right tools
so then how do we begin to overcome
these barriers before data can be
actionable in real time using ml
since our Inception Google has been
focused on delivering highly
personalized information that is highly
trusted by billions of people around the
world
data is in our DNA
the same data infrastructure that's
allowed us to innovate is available to
you and that is why we believe we can
make this prediction a reality
take for example our customer Vodafone
as one of the world's largest
telecommunication companies Vodafone
unified all their data so that thousands
of their employees can innovate across
700 different use cases and 5 000
real-time data feeds
they now run AI development 80 faster
more cost effective all without
compromising governance and reliability
so then how can we help you achieve your
own data infrastructure vision
the short answer is in three parts
first you can't act on data unless you
can see it and trust it
today we're announcing automatic
cataloging of all your gcp data with
business context in dataplex
and you can integrate third-party
sources too
what this means is is that you no longer
need to spend days looking for the right
data and instead can spend time working
with it
but once you find your data
do you know you can trust it
have you ever been in a meeting where
someone questions the validity of a
single data point and then nobody can
trust anything that's being presented
from that point onward
that's why I'm particularly excited
about the new data quality and lineage
capabilities and dataplex bringing
intelligence and automation to help you
trust your data
second you can't act on data unless you
can work with it
yeah wait you've got to be able to use
the best tools for the job across all
your data
speaking of the best tools I'm excited
about bigquery's new support for
unstructured data
now you can be sure that you can your
bigquery skills will pay off across all
your data from structure to
semi-structured to unstructured
it is also important to be able to use
the best of Open Source tools
last year we introduced our serverless
spark offering
and today we're announcing that you can
run spark directly from bigquery with
fully integrated experience and billing
but this is still just the beginning
we have a bold vision for our spark
offering to break the Google
infrastructure magic all without forking
open source
take for example mind mouth
the shuffle service powering bigquery
and dataflow that helps deliver scale
reliability and performance that you
know and love with those services
that's coming to a spark job soon
lastly you can't act on today's data
tomorrow
we've heard from many of you that you
struggle with making real time in
context experiences a reality for your
own customers
data flow a streaming analytics service
Powers critical Google services and we
believe it can do the same for you
with dataflow you can use Apache beam to
build the unified batch in real-time
Pipelines
you can start small while having the
assurance that you can process real-time
events at extreme scale if your
application needs it
to summarize when you can see the data
trust the data and work with data as
it's collected we can see how 90 of data
will be actionable in real time using ML
and the incredible Innovation that that
will unleash thank you very much
[Music]
all right
I'm Andy groupmans and I predict that by
the end of 2025 the barriers between
transactional and analytical workloads
will disappear
traditionally data architectures have
separated these mixed workloads and for
good reason
fundamentally they're underlying
databases are built differently
transactional databases are optimized
for fast reads and rights well
analytical databases are optimized for
aggregating large data sets because
these systems are largely decoupled many
of you are struggling to piece together
different solutions to build intelligent
data-driven apps
for instance to provide personalized
recommendations for e-commerce apps need
to support both transactional and
analytical workloads on the same data
set and without negatively impacting
performance
at Google Cloud we're uniquely
positioned to solve this problem because
of how we've architected our data
platform
our transactional and analytical
databases are built on a highly scalable
disaggregated compute and storage system
and Google's high performance Global
Network allowing us to provide tightly
integrated data services
and to help you unify your data across
your apps today I'm excited to tell you
more about new capabilities we recently
announced
First Data stream for bigquery which
allows you to easily replicate data from
transactional databases into bigquery in
real time
next database migration service which
provides a one-click migration from
postgres into alloy DB for operational
Analytics
and lastly we support query Federation
with spanner Cloud SQL and bigtable
right from the bigquery console to
analyze data in transactional databases
but don't take my word for it let's see
how some of these Technologies remove
barriers for our fictitious company
symbol Bank
symbol wanted to integrate their core
banking features in their app with
Market data to provide personalized
real-time investment dashboards
the problem was their app's back end was
optimized for transactional workloads so
how do they maintain the responsiveness
of their app while adding analytical
goodness
symbol Bank chose Google Cloud's new
fully managed postgres compatible
database alloy DB offering the
capability to analyze transactional data
in real time
now migrating all their existing data
with minimal downtime felt like a big
lift for the symbol Engineers but it
turns out that database migration
service makes this simple
and I'll walk you through just how easy
it is
database migration service lets you
migrate from postgres to alloy DB with
continuous replication minimizing
downtime
once we Define where we're migrating
from and we're moving our data into we
can see the prerequisites for the
migration directly in our in your UI
sources are defined using profiles which
contain host username and password and
you can pre-define them like I've done
here for symbols postgres instance
here we Define our destination and some
basic configuration options and then we
get to hit create
this part will take a few minutes so
I've sped up time a little bit
once it finishes a quick test to ensure
that it will all work
and then hit create and start
once the initial dump is finished we're
now in a state where we have both the
old and new database populated with our
live data continuously replicating from
altenew and that means we can do cool
stuff like testing the performance of
our new investment features against both
existing production postgres database
and the new alloy DB database side by
side
since hello ADB is fully compatible with
postgres you don't have to make any
application changes and as you can see
we're getting much better performance
out of the new adodb backend
adoadb is four times faster for
transactional workloads and up to a
hundred times faster for analytical
queries compared to standard postgres
making it the perfect database for these
kind of hybrid workloads
we all want to act on data in real time
without the toil of infrastructure
assembly and operations we've given you
a taste of how Google cloud makes it
easier for you to build data-driven apps
on a unified platform
and this is why I predict that by the
end of 2025 the barriers between
transactional and analytical workloads
will disappear thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Amin vadat and my prediction
is by the end of 2025 over half of cloud
infrastructure decisions will be
automated based on organization's usage
patterns to meet performance and
reliability needs
at Google we believe the work we do
today with our partners will Define the
next generation of infrastructure for
the world
while some people look at infrastructure
as a commodity we see it as a source of
inspiration
this inspiration comes from delivering
capabilities not available anywhere else
and pulling in the future by operating
at a level of reliability and scale that
might otherwise seem unimaginable
our infrastructure is designed with the
scale out capability needed to support
billions of users who use services like
search Youtube Gmail and our cloud
services each and every day
we pioneered the model of entire
buildings operating as a single
Computing and storage system now with
spanner we showed how Services could run
reliably at scale across the planet
and we've experienced Network
Innovations like Google global cash B4
and Jupiter
shortening distances across the planet
this gave us the opportunity to
reimagine what was possible from
infrastructure in terms of scale and
capability
look at the world around us the time for
disruptive innovation has never been
more profound
we're seeing incredible Demand on the
industry's infrastructure
yet simultaneous plateaus and efficiency
you and your companies continue to push
the boundaries of what infrastructure
can provide
yet the burden of picking the just right
combination of components continues to
fall on you
to address this we've engineered golden
paths from Silicon to the console these
paths combine purpose-built
infrastructure prescriptive
architectures and an ecosystem to
deliver workload optimized Ultra
reliable infrastructure
so let's talk about the Investments
we're making in infrastructure at Google
in power and performance to make all
this possible
we partnered with Intel to co-design and
build custom silicon like this little
thing
this is called an infrastructure
Processing Unit or ipu and it gives you
massive performance and scalability
to power high performance data intensive
apps
these ipus are at the heart of our new
C3 VMS
c3s include the latest generation Intel
Sapphire Rapids processor and custom
designed offload based on the ipu that
delivers 200 gigabit per second low
latency networking
uncoupled with our new block storage
hyperdisc that can provide incredible
storage performance
now let me show you something else
from the big to the from the small to
The Big Meet the hardware behind the new
tensor Processing Unit the TPU V4
platform it's likely the world's fastest
largest and most efficient machine
learning supercomputer
this liquid-cooled board is a beast in
both power and performance density
you see these pipes running across it
running chilled water over the board
they're there to ensure you extract the
highest level efficiency from this
Hardware
it allows secure isolated access and is
at The Cutting Edge of services like
natural language understanding
recommender systems and image processing
the TPU makes large-scale training
workloads up to 80 faster and up to 50
cheaper compared to alternatives when
you talk about nearly doubling
performance for half the cost you unlock
your imagination in terms of what just
might be possible
the same ipus and tpus that power your
services are the foundation that will
enable us to automate over half of cloud
infrastructure decisions in the next
couple of years
they will support the Telemetry data and
ml based analytics to proactively
recommend the best infrastructure
it will be based on an understanding of
how infrastructure balance points
correspond to Performance and
reliability for your individual
workloads
we don't think that you should have to
think about Hardware specifications
that is the last generation Cloud
thinking
you will specify a workload and will
quickly recommend configure and place
the best option for you based on your
price performance and scale needs
we know that these automated adaptive
decisions deliver lower costs more
performance and higher reliability than
any handcrafted solution
so it's my prediction that over half a
cloud infrastructure decisions will be
automated based on organization's usage
pattern correct honestly I think it's
going to be much higher than that it has
to be in order to keep up with all the
advancements you're making in technology
the burden and complexity of
infrastructure decision making you have
today will disappear through the power
of AI and ml automation
and when you have freedom to focus on
your solution delivery the rate of
innovation and customer benefits will
only accelerate
while cloud has been transformative we
are still at the early stages
we're excited to continue to make the
unimaginable possible and the possible
easy thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi my name is Taran janini and my
prediction is that by the end of 2025
three out of four developers will lead
with sustainability as their primary
development principle
for the longest time the focus was
elsewhere we needed to build it fast
build it securely build it as simply as
possible build it at the lowest cost
build it reliably well now it's also
time to build it sustainably
we can't ignore the urgency required
from all of us to meet climate targets
and while organizations are moving in
the right direction they struggle to
take action
65 percent of I.T Executives said they
want to improve their sustainability
efforts but don't know how to do it
36 percent of them said they didn't even
have the measurement Tools in place to
track sustainability progress
so how can we help them out
we can give them better data about the
environmental footprint of their
business
so today I am excited to announce that
Google Cloud carbon footprint which
helps you measure report and reduce your
Cloud carbon emissions is now generally
available
thank you
let's take a look
right from the cloud console you can
access the carbon footprint dashboard of
your account
the underlying methodology is quite
unique and is based on actual
measurements of the energy used by
machines in our data center
it is also the complete picture of your
emissions
not only emissions coming from
electricity production but also on-site
fossil fuel emissions and other embodied
emissions coming from data center
Hardware this is also known as Scopes 1
2 and 3.
and of course you can break down the
data by Google Cloud project Google
Cloud region and Google Cloud product
with a simple click
you can export your Cloud emissions data
to bigquery for further analysis and to
provide your sustainability teams with
the data they need to report on your
company's emissions
we also want to help you build new
applications that emit less carbon by
making the right choice at the right
time
let's say you want to deploy a new
application to the US West Coast
from a latency perspective all of these
options are very similar
without more info
you might have picked Las Vegas which
happens to have a relatively carbon
intense electricity grid
but up in Oregon you would find a very
clean grid full of hydropower and
therefore low carbon intensity that is
why it is indicated as a low carbon
region
in fact a simple choice of a of Oregon
Over Las Vegas can reduce your gross
electricity emissions of running that
app by about 80 percent
and with this move you not only saved
carbon you also saved money since a
compute engine VM is cheaper in Oregon
a move that can help you save money and
carbon is easy to make when we tested
this feature we noticed new users were
50 percent more likely to choose a low
carbon region when they saw the icon and
that can make a very big difference
so how do we make it easy to identify
more opportunities to lower your carbon
emissions and deliver those options at
scale
well active assist now shares
recommendations to remove idle resources
and their Associated emissions
actually all of the sustainability
features I just showed you today are
embedded into Google Cloud console and
documentation
they are available out of the box at no
charge and for all Developers
sustainability is too important to be
complicated
before I go here are two things to
remember
one moving to Google Cloud gives you the
efficiency gains and energy benefits to
reduce your emissions
two
when you build on the cloud pick the
region with the lowest carbon impact for
your application
because these tools are available I
believe that by 2025 three out of four
developers will lead with sustainability
as their primary development principle
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's play with that weird energy though
together here today let's go good so hi
my name is Richard sirroder my
prediction for you today is that by the
end of 2025 over half of all
organizations using public Cloud we're
actually going to freely switch their
primary Cloud as a result of all these
new multi-cloud capabilities available
so quick story I recently moved from the
Seattle area to San Diego after a
vacation this year with my family you
realize we needed something different so
bought a house in San Diego before I
finally sold the house in Washington and
for a weird time there I was multi-house
and that was not good but it wasn't it
wasn't my desired end state but that's
okay sometimes you're in these multi
situations while you transfer from one
state to another and that's related to
my prediction here I think in the years
ahead we're going to see companies use a
multi-cloud strategy not just as a way
to hedge their bets but as a way to
actually switch from their first Cloud
to their next cloud
so research data shows that the majority
of companies are actually multi-cloud
today meaning they use more than one
hyperscale Cloud sounds probably pretty
familiar to most of you I'm personally
talking to more and more companies
though they're using multi-cloud
Technologies as a way not to shift their
just their workload but their mind share
to the different Cloud as well so let's
see what that Journey might look like
what would that look like it's looking
like three different steps we'll do some
live demos what can go wrong so first
that first part of the journey is how do
we meet you where you are today with
what you got you probably use another
Cloud that's totally cool Nobody's
Perfect
but here at Google Cloud we've made some
unique investments in a multi-cloud
management plane that works with your
compute and your data even if it's on
other clouds so in this first step
you're starting to use Google Cloud but
you want to incorporate existing
investments in other ones so consistency
matters a ton here and anthos plays a
huge part let's see how so first off if
you'll see here I actually have an eks
cluster I built and I've actually
attached this to the anthos control
plane from here I can manage the cluster
I can view workloads I can deploy things
I can troubleshoot I can apply common
policies and even with our
recent partnership and collaboration
with the cross-plane project I can
actually create and manage gke clusters
AKs clusters eks clusters provision and
manage them all the same way from Google
Cloud which is pretty cool
now what do you do with your data we
talked about compute if I think about my
data how do I analyze all this we know
that data transfer costs are real
consolidation isn't always the right
option so for financial strategic or
even policy reasons your organization
might need data in different clouds it's
okay
so with bigquery Omni IAC can actually
have my data Lake in Amazon S3 or here
in my Azure storage account and I don't
have to move the data to actually run my
queries against it in bigquery I can
actually analyze it where it resides
without moving the data so this is one
of many Google cloud services that
actually work wherever you are whether
they run across clouds or actually
integrate with the different clouds it's
a big deal so that's a starter phase
right I'm building skills I'm moving you
know kind of comfort in this new home I
have but I haven't moved really anything
so some of you might think this is where
you stop right multi-cloud is just use a
bunch of clouds but I don't think so I
think many are going a step further
so in the second stage you start
upgrading your Tech where it is and
growing your adoption of that secondary
cloud
so step two as I start using Google
cloud services let's say things like gke
which are awesome I want to use it even
more and more so I might introduce
things like
amp those clusters to Azure and AWS this
is the gke API and gke software running
across clouds which is amazing and just
now we just shipped the capability where
I can even upgrade those clusters in
place on another cloud from the Google
Cloud console that's awesome I don't
have to jump all over the place to run
all my infrastructure
now here you might also start creating a
multi-cloud mesh and say look I want to
actually maintain services that run
across clusters in different clouds in
this particular mesh my web app is
spread across gke eks clusters all of
these different places I'm actually able
to manage those services and see them
and connect them wherever they are
but let's talk about data at this point
in the game you might use our great
service data stream to redirect your
existing Aurora cluster in AWS from
redshift maybe you want to steer it to
bigquery instead and I actually built a
stream that connects from my Aurora
database and feeds the data in real time
to bigquery pretty awesome stuff so use
data stream to move data around as well
so that's cool so for some multi-cloud
is a bit of a phase it's not a permanent
State you're not trying to get there
your final stage could be a full-on
migration to your new primary cloud
so once you've invested in Google Cloud
you might start taking advantage of
really awesome stuff like gke autopilot
this is a fully managed kubernetes
environment where we are running the
whole thing you don't manage clusters
you just deal with your workloads it's
awesome and exclusive to Google Cloud
now what's really cool is you may also
continue to use anthos on Google Cloud
to manage all of your fleets of gke
clusters at all of our regions around
the world I'm showing you some new
dashboards here that are coming out and
this actually actually lets me manage
not just my gke clusters but I'm
managing on-prem bare metal VMware Edge
doesn't matter I'm getting a view of my
entire fleet and managing that so now
you get things like bigquery for
analytics you're in Google Cloud spanner
for distributed data AIML for amazing
insights all these unique developer
tools and more so look if you forget
everything else that I've talked about
here today remember that Google cloud
has a really unique management plane
that meets you where you are but
honestly takes you further
so this is why I believe over half of
companies using public Cloud today will
freely switch their primary provider in
the coming years as a result of all
these great multi-clack capabilities
thanks a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
and my prediction is that by the end of
2025 over half of all business
applications will be built by users who
do not identify as professional
developers today
one of the most interesting
opportunities as organizations evolve is
that we will continue to see more
development work in the Enterprise taken
up by teams and individuals outside of
central I.T
the adoption of no Code and low code
tools will unlock this potential by
making the development process easier
for more users
how many times have you been asked to do
something but you had to say no because
your roadmap or feature request lists
were already way too long
well with these tools those business
users you had to say no to can instead
create apps and workflow automations
themselves with no programming skills
required
these no Code and low code apps will be
built collaboratively with developers
like you who will provide the guard
rails to keep the business secure while
enabling business users to deliver their
own Solutions
and I'm not alone in thinking this
prediction will come true
leading Tech analyst Gardener forecasts
that by 2025 70 of new applications
developed by organizations will use low
code or no code Technologies that's up
from less than 25 in 2020.
organizations are getting ready for this
change and our customers are already
moving in this direction
Globe Telecom a major Telco out of the
Philippines reduced targeted business
process turnaround time by 80 percent
through experiences built by their
citizen Developers
and now it's demo time let me show you
how Google workspaces app sheet is
making all this possible today
and in the future
now I'm going to be Anne gray a business
analyst trying to help my team save time
managing request approvals currently the
process is manual and disorganized
spread across ad hoc emails and chat
messages
so to fix that first I'm going to build
a no code request approval app and then
I'll show you how my team and I can use
this app to efficiently manage our
development workflow our approval
workflow with app sheet I have a single
place to store my data and build my apps
I can also connect to other easy to use
data sources like sheets or with the
help of it I could connect to Cloud DBS
let me show you the solution that I
could build as a business user
here's my database appsheet helps me
structure my data and prep it for app
building
when I'm ready I can create a new
application with a single click
this creates a prototype app that will
be usable on any desktop or mobile
device
after some customization here's what
I've built I have a new request view for
users to make requests
and an approval view for approvers to do
their thing
each of these views is available to me
in mobile apps and desktop apps by
default and I can also configure them to
show up in Gmail and chat meeting my
users where they are
here is my Google chat app
with this my users can make requests
directly from their team chat space and
it's reusing the same request view I
configured earlier
here's my automation that will send the
approval view to the approvers in email
when I'm happy with my app I can share
it with my users and I can add it to my
chat spaces
throughout this whole process everything
I created is controlled by governing
policies set by the company's workspace
admin for example here's what happens if
I try to share the app outside of my
domain
she blocks me and keeps company data
secure
this allows it to do two things one keep
a clear line of sight on all apps so
they can deprecate update and retire
them when necessary and two restrict
access to only those users who need it
now let me show you how my colleague
Jeffrey and I can use this app to manage
our request and approval workflow
I'll be Jeffrey now
Nance team and I have a request to make
let me ask and how to use her new app
she's added the bot to the space
and now I can quickly submit my
reimbursement request
okay now the ant again
I got this email for Jeffrey's request I
can review and approve it directly from
here
and if I have a pile of requests to
review I don't have to click through
individual emails I can pop into the app
and see everything in one place
this app is accessible to all the users
requesters and approvers with simple
sheets like Expressions it's configured
so the requesters see only their own
requests and approvers see all the
information that they need
you saw just how easy we are making it
for non-technical users to create
business applications that meet their
immediate needs with no Code and low
code you and your business users now
have more tools to work with
this is why I believe that over half of
all business apps will be built by users
who don't identify as professional
developers today
thank you
well folks that's a wrap on our
predictions we're excited about the
conversations this will start and
continue with all of you
remember if you want to share your own
prediction use the hashtag Google Cloud
predictions to tell us all about it we
can't wait to hear from you
thank you for your continued inspiration
and for partnering with us to build
what's next
so are you ready
enjoy the rest of the show thank you
everyone
hi I'm Shaquille O'Neal and I'm the
founder of big chicken
so you got to do that at the end when
you say big chicken
big chicken is Shaquille O'Neal's
emerging fast casual restaurant chain
that focuses on big fun big flavor and
big food when you're trying to build the
national chain communication is so
critical to do that you need a great
partner we're really lucky that partner
is Google workspace you know Josh every
time he does a presentation he just
loves Google's life as the person
responsible for our marketing probably
the best at Google Slides
this presentation is just like I'm at a
movie sometime I'm just sitting there
going
I've got some great new chicken
sandwiches for you to try brand new
recipes
isn't there something important we're
supposed to be talking about good recipe
development comes with collaboration
using docs in Google workspace gives us
the tools we need to collaborate
together
Shaquille's life gets crazy busy as does
our entire board you want to talk to me
make sure you put on my Google Calendar
Google Calendar is my girlfriend
I don't know anything I'm doing unless I
talk to my woman
Google workspace productivity and
collaboration tools for all the ways you
work
[Music]
Google products provide the information
you need when you need it but why can't
you get the same kind of answers for
your business
looker Google Cloud's business
intelligence solution is here to solve
that problem enabling you to go beyond
traditional dashboards and make your
organization's information accessible
and useful
bringing this Innovation to business
will be revolutionary just like
navigating a city after Google Maps
looker is Google for your business data
here's what we mean what if Google AI
were built into the tools you use to
store and analyze data at work Google's
vertex AI Vision takes data like video
images and audio and in real time turns
it into structured data ready for
business intelligence going beyond the
dashboard means using Google Glass
Enterprise to see insights and
recommendations based on your data in
real time more access more transparency
now that's Google for your business
Google Maps do you know if a restaurant
is busy before you go or you can get
rerouted or at a traffic jam looker will
help you connect similar dots in a
predictive way
a concert in five days will increase
foot traffic by 65 percent would you
like to adjust Staffing and inventory
yes looker and AI lets you respond to
changes in demand and turn insights into
action
foot traffic continues to be busy
encourage customers to visit an
alternate Shop with a reward card yes
smarter insights mean better experiences
and happy customers
to go beyond the dashboard and transform
the way you do business with looker
powered by Google Cloud
we started with the exponential roadmaps
goal the zero carbon emissions by 2050.
where are emissions primarily stem from
device CDM networking and Cloud our goal
is actually to get to zero emissions by
2030. backstage was built internally at
Spotify so it unifies your tooling your
services docs and apps under a unified
consistent UI we donated it to the cloud
native Computing Foundation amazing to
see how many people at Spotify actually
care deeply about this topic Cloud
carbon footprint is actually an open
source tool developed by thoughtworks
the only thing that's limiting us right
now is just people hearing about it it
leverages Cloud apis to provide
visualizations of estimated carbon
emissions we leverage bigtable gke it
starts not just from the cloud but it
goes all the way out to our end user
devices we want to empower not just
Spotify internally but the broader
developer Community reduce their carbon
footprint
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Munich developers and all of those
Europe Middle East and africa-wide
developers following us online
hope you are all well fed now and ready
for more content
so we've got a great session coming your
way now in fact I had the honor to meet
our next speaker at an event in
Frankfurt Germany earlier this year and
I was personally very inspired by her
story and I think many of you will be
too
so up next I'd like to welcome Chanel
Greco a developer advocate for Google
workspace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey there so my name is Chanel and today
I'm going to tell you a personal story
so it's my story as a woman in Tech the
ups and the downs but more importantly
what I've learned from it and hopefully
also inspiration for you
a while ago I read a very interesting
book it's called Atomic Habits by James
Clear maybe some of you have read it too
and
um it speaks about atoms so atoms are
the smallest particle of an element of a
chemical element I know that so exactly
because I Googled it and it speaks in
the book about how tiny little tweaks to
habits you already have or maybe even
stacking new habits upon each other so
doing little improvements can have a
compounding effect and lead to real
change in whatever we're trying to
improve so I want to have you keep that
concept of atomic habits in the back of
your mind as I tell you what I
experienced now
let's start off by looking at my first
learning and it has to do with the
decision I had to make and admittedly
well I made the wrong decision but let
me tell you why I made that wrong
decision
well you see
at a very young age I was about eight or
nine something like that I fell in love
I would call this it was love up first
click because I started playing computer
games and I was fascinated by this as a
matter of fact today a bit more than 30
years later I still consider myself a
gamer one of my favorite ways of
unwinding is switching all my console
and this love of computer games after a
while it triggered real interest in
technology
and I could imagine working in
information technology
at a very young age I had to decide okay
so what am I going to do what am I going
to be what am I going to make out of my
life and when I mean young age I mean
really young I was 14. so you see in the
country where I grew up traditionally
especially when I was a teenager
two-thirds of high school students would
then go on and do an apprenticeship so
that means two days a week usually you
go to business school and then the rest
you work on site with your team at the
company that hires you so I knew I
wanted to do that and not go to
university simply because I wanted to
earn money so I knew I wanted to do an
apprenticeship so that meant at 14 I had
to start applying to these companies
so the question was what what exactly
are you going to apply for what for a
job are you going to apply for now deep
inside myself I knew I wanted to work in
Information Technology but there was a
big big problem because for me this is
what working in an information
technology business meant working with
much older men and being the only girl
in Business School
now
you have to keep in mind I was 14. now I
don't know about you but when I was a
teenager it was all about fitting in and
not being the odd one out you wanted to
be with the cool kids you wanted to be
with everyone else and not be the weirdo
in the class so for me that fear of
being the only girl or working on a team
with a much older men was real after all
I know no no women who worked in
technology I literally only knew men
now as I Was preparing this talk
I asked myself well wait a minute I
after all you were 14. you lived in a
town outside of the big city what if
your assessment of the situation of that
there was no women in technology was
wrong what if you were the problem
so I did a little bit of research and I
found the statistics for the company
excuse me for the country where I grew
up
in
but before you before I show you that I
want to do a little quiz because have
you noticed I kept on saying the country
where I grew up in but I didn't tell you
which country it is now obviously for
those of you who might know me here you
don't get to guess but for all the
others who don't know it I'm gonna give
you three hints and let's see if you get
it right and maybe maybe Emily has some
swag for you because I don't so first of
all first hint is it's a European
country
second and this is going to make a bit
more interesting we have the highest
consumed per person when it comes to
Chocolate worldwide
yep
Switzerland exactly the third hint would
have been obviously cheese melt the
cheese on top of potatoes or dipping
bread in melted cheese but anyway so
you're all wet Fed so you don't need any
fondue so exactly these are the
statistics for Switzerland
and we have on the left side for
apprenticeship so this is typically a
four year apprenticeship that you enroll
in and then on the right side we have
University the year is 1999 why well
because that's the year I
um back then at 15 enrolled in my
studies so we see 7.3 percent of the
students that enrolled in apprenticeship
were female and 10.9 in University who
started studying information technology
so when I saw this statistic I thought
to myself well 14 year old you was
probably spot on with your assessment of
the situation because I most likely
would have been the only girl in school
and
probably or definitely would have been
the only young girl in a team with much
older men but surely 2022 things are
much better well nah not really things
have improved but we're not there yet so
we have for 2019 on the left side and
for 2020
um the newest statistics so Improvement
there but we haven't quite reached where
we want to be now what did I learn from
this
I strive to be a role model for young
girls and women and get them excited
about technology because I as a young
girl lacked that moment of seeing Oh if
she can do it then I can do it now this
talk is from my perspective a woman in
technology but if you are part of a
minority group that is underrepresented
in technology well the same is true for
you you can be a role model for the
people from your minority group that
they can look at you and say well if
that person can do it then I can do it
too
now on to my second learning
after a couple of years and by the way I
didn't tell you what I I ended up
enrolling in as studies so I did an
office clerk apprenticeship and
typically girls can go on to
um do stuff like PR HR marketing so kind
of like the typical women's job I ended
up in bookkeeping my worst job ever so
after a while I was able to ditch that
and I I got the opportunity to start
working as a hardware supporter and
obviously I worked in a team that was
well almost
exclusively male but I was really intent
on you know giving my best and learning
as as fast as I could
and part of me learning a new skill has
always been
buying books so I had a nice big book
about computers sitting on my desk and I
remember one of the technicians came
over to me to talk about some customer
support case and he picked up the book
on my desk and he looked at it and he
started laughing he was like what you
still have to read books about computers
and I remember how hurt I felt because
here I was given my all and he thought
it was okay to make fun of me that I
didn't have the experience that he had
now a couple of years later
I started working for another company
and I was lucky enough to have managers
who believed in my potential and they
gave me projects to manage so I was an
I.T project manager and I remember one
day one of my colleagues who worked on a
team with me said do you know Chanel
what the engineers say about you from
the engineering team well obviously not
they don't tell me so he said well you
know they say Chanel is cute but her
technical skills aren't the best
and if I or when I think of that
statement I must say
with the second part they were spot on
again because here I was
um in contrast to them I hadn't studied
computer science or information
technology like they did I was someone
learning on the job you know doing
courses in the evening so they had
studied
they were usually 10 to 20 years older
than me so they had much more on the job
experience so yes their assessment of my
technical skills I wasn't at the level
that they were but here's the thing I
cannot imagine them saying well you know
Luke is cute or Luke is athletically
built but his technical skills aren't
the best so it's okay to say something
like that about a woman
and that's what bothers me about that
statement
now what did I learn from these two
situations whenever possible I
personally prefer working in diverse
teams because later on in my career when
I did also work as a developer I worked
in diverse teams and obviously diversity
is more than just gender it's people
from you know that are very different
from each other and in those teams I
felt safest and I also performed the
best because I think when you feel safe
that's when you can excel
now I believe there's also another
reason why we need diversity now as
software developers we're creating
solutions for problems that are very
diverse set of people of users need and
will be using so wouldn't it make sense
that the teams working on these
Solutions are also diverse as possible
and I can imagine the most of you here
or if you're in a position to hire that
you definitely also want to hire for
diversity
now on to the third learning that I had
and it has to do with something that I
personally think is my superpower in the
sense of that for me it unlocked many
doors and it's also the reason why I'm
here today why I'm able to do my job as
a developer advocate for Google
workspace and it has to do with that in
May 2015 even though I have been in it
for a long time
I finally decided I really want to learn
how to code I set my mind on that
maybe you could say I was a little bit
naive because I had no idea how
difficult it was going to be so I signed
up for rails girls Zurich
and rails girls is an initiative
originally from Finland where during a
weekend for example a lot of women come
together and learn how to code as a
matter of fact I remember there weren't
only people living in Switzerland there
even from the south of Germany a lot of
women traveled to Zurich to be able to
be part of that boot camp and the way it
works is that you have these smaller
groups so you you break up the
participants into smaller groups and
each group's group has a coach that
teaches you the fundamental of Ruby and
Ruby on Rails the framework
now by the way these weren't only female
coaches there were actually more men
male coaches than female ones there
so for me this changed everything this
coding boot camp and when I think back
to that weekend there's certain things
that I vividly remember one thing I was
totally overwhelmed I wasn't
understanding half of what they were
telling us but we were in an environment
there was this atmosphere around us
where it was okay for us to say I'm
sorry I didn't get that could you
explain it maybe a little bit
differently so we felt safe to be
ourselves and to learn together and to
yeah you know also be okay to say I'm
sorry I didn't get that and on the other
hand
with these people who were coaches I
after a couple of months already started
coaching too at events and at boot camps
and some of these coaches who really
encouraged me to get into technology did
actually become my colleagues because I
did stick to coding and I became a full
stack developer for Ruby on Rails so you
could really say this fundamentally
changed my life now what is my learning
from this that I experienced well
whenever possible I like to be a mentor
or a coach at coding events for girls or
for women and for a while I worked as a
coding teacher and there was a special
I.T week where schools in Zurich sent
um classes
to learn about information technology
and I had one class girls around what
were they maybe nine or ten years old
and I showed them how to write HTML and
CSS and that is incredibly rewarding to
see these girls having fun with
technology and hopefully that also in
the future they remember how that was
and also decide to get into information
technology
now I personally invite you if you are a
developer or if you have coding skills
to have a look at this opportunity to
also become a coach a mentor and to make
this a little bit more tangible for you
here are a couple of the initiatives
that you can maybe have a look at and
maybe even sign up to as a coach or
Mentor now I specifically also want to
mention the women tech maker initiative
by Google because this is a global
initiative so you will find Chapters in
Berlin Zurich Nairobi Lagos Paris London
and so on so I definitely invite you to
have a look at that
now I would love to connect with you as
a matter of fact here are my social
media profiles you can scan them
because I would really like to know how
you see this situation maybe what your
experience was and if you agree with
what I said or maybe you even have cool
ideas that I haven't thought of now
let's come full circle to what I told
you in the beginning to keep that about
Atomic habits in mind
if you think about it
you and I
we're atoms we're the smallest elements
or particles of our families of our
teams
of the communities we're part of
now if we make maybe little changes
maybe one change that I mentioned here
that can have a compounding effect and
we can drive diversity in Tech
from bottom up thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing
reasons
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey developers welcome back and now
we're heading into a Super Key topic
area regardless of your company or your
Tech Focus security
so please welcome our next speaker who
is a hybrid multi-cloud fellow he's
going to talk about how to check your
security posture so welcome Jason quick
the global CTO of Devo team Google Cloud
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone thank you for joining my
session today today I'm going to talk
about a very important topic about
checking your security posture in Google
Cloud
so first of all I'd like to give a bit
of background where do we come from and
why I'm on the stage talking about this
so when we first moved to Google Cloud
we decided that we were going pure Cloud
native the number one priority for us
was developer eligibility so how do we
get the productivity to build products
and applications on the cloud as fast as
you can and as cleanly as you can
and we also had to combat the client
changing Cloud landscape with continuous
new features and releases that you see
in the cloud next
uh all the time so understanding what to
use and what not to use in our Cloud
landscape
so devil team gcloud is a Google Cloud
managed Services partner with a global
presence which means that we are present
in 18 countries so which means also
different different kind of regulations
and different kind of rules they have to
apply for all customers that sit across
the globe
and it's not an easy thing to do
and we also have to pass different
things like the audit so to become
managed Services partner in Google Cloud
you actually get audited by Google
itself and that's kind of stressful at
times so in one section it's about
security how do you maintain a good
security posture so that you can give
secure a peace of mind to your customers
we also have many specializations in
which of them they go through our
security posture and validate that we
are secure and we are poised to uh for
success
so it can feel hard to create a secure
Cloud environment because there's so
many rules there's many features things
like organization policies things like
security Command Center things like IM
rules so it can feel hard at times to
what do you enable and what do you
disable in your Cloud environment
so a bit of context as well in 2018 we
started on Google cloud with what I call
the cloud foundations so building what
the technical Landing Zone with the
different kind of governance in place
next we move to gke and utilize that to
great effect we go into githubs and we
can start with antos
and 2020 that's where we achieved our
managed services provider status so that
we can give that kind of a extra service
to our customers
and next we build things like
accelerators in a different waveform
workloads
now
so in back in 2018 to bring you back a
couple of years ago like four years back
there was a few different requirements
where to look at our Landing zone right
first we had to work on this different
different customers proof of Concepts so
you're building different pocs you're
using different kind of customer
environments so you have to build a
multi-tandent strategy
secondly we want to test out new
features on Google Cloud to be ahead of
the curve to understand what is going to
be the next Trend in the market and what
should we get ahead of to learn
and next we want to do it as automated
as possible because if you want to know
there's a big lack of talent in the
Google Cloud Market we need much more
developers much more clock attacks in
the market to get Google Cloud really
running as cool as possible so as a
byproduct automation is key
next we want to make it intuitive and
easy to navigate for example if you want
to onboard a new engineer they should be
able to look at the cloud landscape and
understand where to go how to navigate
and how to build things so it should be
as close to best practices as possible
so that we do not have to reinvent The
View
and next last thing and finally is to be
secure because we cannot lose
information and data right
so with that we looked around the five
uh six main topics so with things like
governance networking logging monitoring
security building because for example
building actually is a key part of
security as well how to prevent BioShock
we have to make it multi-tenant with
different customers sitting in different
environments as well as our own sandbox
environments for our developers
as uh and so and also we run internal
applications for customers as well
so you can imagine it's a very large
multi-tenant environment with different
regulations different kind of rules for
different countries so it's a quite a
sprawling landscape so we sit almost
across three organizations if you if you
know the organizational note in Google
Cloud
thousands of projects hundreds of
folders
so in 2020 we we took a step back
because those were really the cloud
really boomed and we said that okay we
need to identify which Technologies were
really key to get on board so that we
can leverage and accelerate
so first of all we say that okay we're
going to go with terraform right we're
not going to go with Cloud deployment
manager so to kind of adopt an open open
way of working I see some last in the
audience we looked at things like Cloud
build Argo CD which we found that really
fitted on the way we work uh that
decorative way of working
and we came across also this idea of the
Google Cloud foundations
right and what is Google Cloud
foundations
this is where we realized that we had to
use this great tool that was produced as
open source it's called the cloud
Foundation toolkit scorecard so remember
the the scenario we came from we had a
large sprawling Cloud landscape with
multiple projects that fit with multiple
use cases pocs sandboxes production
environment staging environments that
you have teams in different countries
building all the time and delivering all
the time for over 2000 customers
how do we score ourselves on security so
this is where this came in uh I can
recommend you can do that so what you do
is that you can write what I call
policies so this is a very typical
policy they can download from the from
the source reports so it's a very simple
one it's just basically anybody does not
come should never be older in the in in
your project very simple very simple
rule right
so with discount policies um I would
want to do a walk through so the first
step there's three easy way steps to do
this to check your Cloud security
posture today so three easy steps to get
get rated number one export your asset
inventory so understanding what sits in
your Cloud right just simply run this
GitHub commands is easy peasy and you
get a list of all your service accounts
firewall rules applications everything
comes out in a huge Json file
it covers things like iron rules as well
as resources
next you get your policy library from
for safety security I'm not sure if
anyone has implemented Society before
you can raise your hand
yeah for exactly great awesome yeah it's
I really recommend it as well it's a
continuously check checking your
security posture
so there's a great base policy Library
here so it gives you like the basic
defaults things like that um on the
owner rules right
clone it and then just run this command
CFT scorecard and you point to a policy
path
and you and you point to where your
bucket sits where you have your asset
inventory
with that you get a list of violations
and the violations as well will link to
the different kind of rules that uh that
you have implemented in your policy
Library
so how do we tackle all these different
rules as well like what do we start with
first
so first we tackle the IM violations
because first we want to make sure that
no one's accessing the system that
shouldn't be accessing the system right
so
throughout the experience with customers
and with other people as well like a
simple thing like
restricting the age of how long your
service account key can live for
so for example how many of you have
service count keys that have been
floating around for example if you're a
new Joiner yeah or a person that left
the company and they bring along the
service account key with them so
actually if you don't have a rotation
policy today this thing will pop up as a
violation so you have a service account
keys that has lived for longer than for
some hundred days
this also then gives you an insight
about what you have to fix and what
policy you have to you have to implement
so this could be maybe a missing process
in your company onboarding and
onboarding phase so maybe developers
should download a new key every two days
for example from a bucket so make sure
that those keys will never be misused
just let it die and so this was a
typical constraint that we found out
okay we have some service count keys
that have been living for too long we
have deprecated them and really and
rotate them
and also fix our processes right
next we have a rethink the project
creation process so a lot of the kind of
flaws there are issues that we found in
violations was actually due to this how
you create a project right that's
actually a very simple thing to do you
go to Cloud console you click create
project and you're done right
like for example do you know that in we
create a new project in the quotas page
bigquery analysis is unlimited for
example so any developer can create a
project and can consume
twenty thousand quarts of of bigquery
that's cost within one day if they're
not careful
so how do you do that in a way that you
can actually uh be make sure that you
are as secure as possible
so we had to fix issues at the road so
we started writing additional
constraints so one of them for example
is identifying course cost owners and
countries of where they sit so making
sure that each project has its owner and
and also have a have a PR request rule
so that when you try to create projects
it must be validated by the CTO of the
country
so when we scan when I scan our hot
landscape as well we found that there
are many ways of labeling there was not
uh it's always hard to follow rules with
on Confluence for example when you
create a you create a documentation you
say that I want you to do this same way
most of the time it gets out of skew so
you need to still monitor it and see
which of this things that you have
documented down whether the processes
are followed so trust but always verify
so this is a way of verifying it
next we also have to think about
revoking our modules so remember we
chose terraform right and we started to
build with terraform and we start to use
our modulus and we use a lot of Open
Source terraform modules so we just grab
Gary off from get GitHub
uh from uh Cloud Foundation
uh and we start to use them we want to
go fast right that's how you really
leverage open source
but we realized that you cannot assume
that open source actually automatically
meets all your needs of each customer
and this is the reason why we have to
create our own telephone modules they
were specific to gke pops up ASM for
example enter service mesh and I'll give
you a bit of argue example why
so if you go to the next slide like for
example in this this is a copy paste
from uh uh public GitHub repo for ASM so
in here when you create an enter service
mesh
on a GK cluster you enable the GK Hub
feature in the same code in the same
module right which means if you create
five enter service measures across five
clusters and if you destroy one of them
it will disable the feature for the
entire project
so this is kind of things that you have
to actually investigate when you look at
open source as well to see that even
though it is uh is something published
open source is public is well tested you
have to see does it fit your need and
can you understand what goes on
underneath as well
and this is what I realized doing doing
our security posture check
so that's what I found out so you only
will discover this when you try to
destroy the ASM you realize that oh
suddenly the features disabled
and lastly we start to think about even
extend it further and do definition of
additional rules
so for example we have many customers
within FSI Healthcare Manufacturing
and all of them have different kind of
data locality requirements for example
so creating uh location violations so
understanding that some of the data sets
can only sit in certain location gives
you a way to verify their data should
only be in a different area if you do
the same thing for your GK clusters for
your your cloud storage buckets and so
and so forth so you can basically the
developer does something wrong they can
they'll be notified when you do a next
scan right
and this really make it very easy to to
adopt a pulse yes code approach uh which
you find works better
than merely maintaining a bunch of rules
as documentation
so some of the learnings that we had
uh so The Code by library page always
work hard on something uncomfortably
exciting
so why do I quite uncomfort
uncomfortably exciting with security
because
honestly who wants to look at your own
security rules at times because you're
worried okay I made something wrong I
did something wrong I might be the
reason for this security breach
so it's very important to open up those
those problems that surface up to
yourself rather than letting some
attacker or some some outside adversary
discovery on your own so it's
uncomfortable but do it do check your
security posture
so and also with open source systems so
we will look at our security posture as
well we found out that um you know a lot
of cves are trying being updated over
time how deployed and as well as when we
recommend an open source system to work
on we also we have to understand can we
support this open source system
ourselves in the event that somebody
stops supporting it starts doing PRS
stop thinking fixing bugs can we go
ahead and fix those bugs ourselves and
this is a great thing we love open
source and we love to we love to use it
but the thing is that if it goes away
from this open source system we'll be
stuck on it and you'll take a few months
to migrate from it so anything we pick
and choose we must go through a
checklist and we see are we able to
understand how can we support it
can we explain how it works so
understanding and explaining how it
works is very important as well
and can we extend it so that can we add
on to it is it something that's
protected and you can rebuild it
so next uh what's next in our list of
activities so in 2023 we're going to
start looking at things like kubernetes
config connector and opa open policy
agent
so like you see the constraints they
have just defined on the screen so
Google has come up with a new way of
working instead of using terraform you
create Google Cloud infrastructure as
yaml files right and you deploy into KCC
which is then instantiate those
resources on your Cloud landscape and
then you use things like open policy
agent to block any misconfigured uh
infrastructure
and that could be a possibility so it's
always important to update on the new on
the latest tech and see that it fit for
us
but we cannot only protect from uh from
attack at the source we also have to do
audits which is why something like the
the cloud Foundation toolkit is always
good to have because you can audit at
the end of the year to make sure that
you're in compliance
and also things like the security
Command Center so there's another
another new feature that Google came up
with I think last year
that has a lot of these constraints they
have defined for you with machine
learning and also with the different
benchmarks that you can easily purchase
and deploy
but right now we have our own policy
library that we maintain and that we use
to regulate our our infrastructure but
it could be a good idea to go to those
two in that
so yeah so it looks very similar you're
creating uh yaml files for like for
example constraint templates for Pub sub
so ensuring that you have the labels yes
always labeled
and it's a basically a gatekeeper so
ensuring that nothing gets gets sent in
that's wrong
and we're securing Command Center uh you
take things the next step so always
doing a asset inventory export so the
whole screen posture is always around
your assets taking the export
trying to figure out is it has it been
any misconfigurations and also do track
detection so that's something that's so
extra
that we're looking at and also what's
nice is that it has the best practices
there as well like CIS NRC which we have
built in our policy libraries but it's
nice to have somebody updating it for us
like moving to a managed service is
always something that we choose to do
also with that um I end my session my
email is actually hidden by the round
thing but if you want to drop me a meal
to ask talk about security or ask for
our policy Library you know well who is
happy to share so it's json.quack
devilteam.com so feel free to drop me a
message anytime yeah I'd love to connect
on LinkedIn as well thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I can't believe you let me down
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
but every now and then it brings us down
[Music]
welcome back everybody and continuing on
the critical topic of security for
Developers
our next talk is how to secure your
software supply chain and you're going
to hear this from a strategic Cloud
engineer who comes from the beautiful
German side of Lake Constance please
welcome Kristoff grotz
[Music]
so good afternoon my name is Christopher
Emily already announced me and today I
would like to speak to you about uh how
you can secure your software supply
chain and what's the things you might
want to look out for
so before we dive into the details I'd
like to give you a quick overview of
software supply chain security and why
it's such an important topic these days
your applications normally consist of
source code that your organizations
create and dependencies that you consume
from third parties
you probably have a build process that
takes the source codes and those
dependencies and creates packaged
software out of that these packages you
either run them in your organization or
maybe other parties consume this
packages as dependencies from you
the dependencies that you are consuming
are provided to you that might be open
source packages or that might be
commercial products from other
contributors so these contributors they
have their own software development life
cycle with their own security processes
in mind
the this as you can see constitutes a
software supply chain where you can be a
consumer of dependencies where you can
be a provider of dependencies or often
you're actually both
this may leave you vulnerable we are
consuming software from a wide range of
resources with unknown contributors and
we don't really have the transparency
into their processes
we are seeing a search in a text on this
Supply software supply chain
sonar type is has noted 650 search in
supply chain attacks year on year
and Gartner is estimating that by 2025
almost half of the world software
organization will have experienced
software supply chain attacks
at Google Cloud we are observing real
world's attacks on a wide range of
vectors in the software development
lifecycle most organizations are
focusing on source code scanning and
vulnerability scanning of the source
code
but with the vectors we observe like a
compromised build system compromise
package repositories in the action of
compromised packages those methods are
not really up to the task
so the question is what can you do to
improve your security posture as you
have already heard in the keynote we're
happy to announce a software delivery
Shield as Google's answer to that
problem
software delivery Shield is a holistic
solution it really tries to help you
from the development all the way into
the runtime it's built on Google
internal best practices like trust-based
policy systems and software delivery
Shield is a modular approach you can
take all of the components together or
you can take individual components and
integrate them with tools you are
already running as part of your software
processes
software delivery Shield supports your
SEC supports your security advices
directly in your IDE and workstations it
helps you with managing the security
posture of your dependencies
it provides out of the box security
capabilities to your build Pipelines and
it helps you with security posture
Management on your runtimes like gke and
Cloud run and with trust-based policy
system you're able to connect all of
those individual Parts together
so let's start with Cloud workstations a
secure software development lifecycle
starts with where the developers
actually develop the code Cloud
workstation provides fully managed
development environments in the cloud
supporting popular Ides like vs code and
IntelliJ
and the other jetbrains IDs it's
designed with security in mind with a
number of features around that
administrators can configure private
interests and private egress they can
configure VPC service controls to
prevent data accelerations and forced
image updates of the workstations make
sure that the developers are always
working on the latest version of the
development environment
with Source protect
we are shift we shift dependency
vulnerability and license awareness left
directly into the IDE of the developer
this gives the developer much faster
feedback increasing productivity when it
comes to closing security gaps this
obviously also works with Cloud
workstations
we improved artifact registry with a
long list of features focused around
security the goal is
to provide insights faster simplify
dependency government governance sorry
and reducing attack vectors
Cloud build now supports out-of-the-box
salsa level freebuilds this means in
addition to already providing ephemeral
and isolated built environments Cloud
build now also provides authenticated
and non-phalsifiable build problems
that's very important if you need to
have auditability on your bills
and sorry one step back in the new
security insights panel I think you've
all seen that in the morning already in
the keynote you get now the sales level
of your build you get the list the SEC
the software bomb of your build you get
vulnerability information and you can
see the build provenance information
we're going to take another look at that
in the demo
on the runtime side we get additional
insights and gke and Cloud run so in gke
we now have a new feature called
security posture management which
continuously scans your gke environment
and gives you recommendations on how you
can configure your workloads with hot
sex security best practices and where
you have vulnerable images and workloads
running in your environment and on cloud
run we also have the security insights
panel that you already know from cloud
built in place so that you can see the
security posture of the container you're
running
to tie everything together binary
authorization allows us to make our
security policies actionable so we can
verify with a binary authorization that
each step of our security process was
executed that we have the attestations
that this image we can trust it we can
run it on how to on our runtimes so gpe
and Cloud run
so next thing is we're going to take a
look at how this all actually connects
into the system we're going to start
with seeing how soft delivery Shield
helps us to create secure containers
by we start with Cloud workstations
we're going to see the features there
we're going to see the insights that it
gives us then we're going to take a look
at how Cloud build helps us to build the
container we're going to take a look at
container analysis for our container
vulnerabilities then we're switching
over to the runtime we're going to check
our binary authorization
um
gives us assurance that only trusted
containers are actually running in the
runtimes and we're going to take a look
at security posture management and how
the insights that we get from there
actually then feedback right into the
developers environment to fix the
problems so
ah sorry then let's move over to the
demo
and of course I need to log in
you know security starts on the
developer machine
that's the cloud workstations overview
panel you can see I already have a
workstation we're going to take a look
into that in a second in Cloud
workstation when you want to create as a
it administrator create a new
configuration so
developer workstations are spawned from
configurations
we get a wide range of features that we
configure on the one hand side we can
make decisions on the on a cost basis
they're not now really security relevant
about how many workstations we want to
have pre-configured already running to
increase product developer productivity
but we can also Define things like
machine types so how big should our
developer machines are be do we need
gpus in case that we're doing AI work on
those machines
we can configure a shielded VMS secure
Boot and so on what you already know
from other parts of gcp
and we can Define the actual developer
environment so we can select uh which
image we want to run so container image
we want to run as a developer
workstation here you can see that's a
bigger list so we have code OSS we have
support for different chat prints Ides
or you can also configure a custom image
if you want to like pre-configure the
developer environment with the tools
that your organization needs and you can
of course also configure storage for
those machines
now
let's jump directly into the workstation
my workstation is already running
I can go here and I need to reload the
window
give it a second you can see it's rather
fast
so in my cloud workstation that I have
here
get rid of that
I have
Java available I have
um should have Maven available yes
wonderful and I'm working in a very
Standard Spring boot project
slightly older version of spring boot
I'm using a new feature from artifact
registry here that's remote repositories
so in artifact registry we as you have
read on one of the slides before we now
support virtual and remote repos so here
I'm I have a cached remote repository
with Maven Central so that you when you
now do a maven clean install
the dependencies are downloaded much
much faster
um then some version configurations and
dependencies but oh no what's that you
can see we have a few linter arrows here
this red curly lines let's hover over
that and that's now
um storage protect so here you can see
that
we have security vulnerabilities Direct
on this dependency let's check the list
out it has a remote code execution in
the spring framework version 5316 but
hey my dependencies actually spring boot
starters web
ah it gives us also dependency inside
this vulnerability insights on
transitive dependencies I mean
I guess you all have at least once in
your life called Maven install and then
it starts downloading half the internet
and maybe you're sitting there and
wondering
what am I actually downloading right now
so it's really important to understand
you might have just one dependency in
Maven and that one might not have
security vulnerabilities but who knows
what you're downloading and with those
transitive dependencies you can be
vulnerable
and what you can also see here that's
what's quite nice for each of these
dependencies if there is already a
version that is that doesn't have this
vulnerability anymore where it's fixed
it gives us also the hint okay if you
update to this minor version for example
you uh the CV is gone
so my my product owner wanted me to do a
fix so I'm just going to ignore that
real quick and
um he really wanted me to push that into
production as fast as possible so let's
just make our small fix
committee the controller
and push it into our hit report
so
Cloud build in a second hopefully should
trigger the build
and then hopefully my build goes into
production
I'm going to skip a little bit uh
in time now because it's going to take
four minutes to run the build and we
don't really have that much time
so that will be the outcome of what we
do so you can see Maven is packaging the
the project no problem with moving very
fine with Maven package we're building
the container pushing it to container to
the artifact registry but
our vulnerability signer doesn't allow
this will not sign this this image so we
don't get an attestation on this image
and the build breaks
that's obviously unfortunate and maybe
we should take a look at why why that is
so let's go to
artifact registry
and take a look at our container image
okay that's the vulnerabilities tab with
the scan result ah okay so critical
levels
vulnerabilities with a high impact
rating not just on the operation system
level of the container but also on the
maven dependencies which is quite
interesting for example here
probably on the next now
spring course bring security so off
there
okay but I really really want to deploy
this container I don't want to allow
what does the attestation even cause
so
obviously the good television book that
I am I prepared the command already to
deploy it let's just put our image in
here and fire away I've guessed
kubernetes will take it anyway
so let's deploy oh
that's binary authorization since the
image doesn't have the proper level of
trust binary this the signing and with
that attestation from the vulnerability
scanner
binary authorization doesn't allow us to
run the image on gke which is great so
now I actually have to take care of all
of the security vulnerabilities
let's just pretend that I did and take a
look at the next build
where I did that ah so now wonderful the
vulnerability signer is giving us green
light it's except the snow
cves that it's complaining about so we
actually get the attestation for our
image and as part of the pipeline we're
triggering a cloud deploy to then deploy
the um the application onto the gke
Clusters
in Cloud build on build artifacts we can
now go to security insights where we get
more information about the build
artifact so on the one hand side you can
see okay there still are some
theoretical and high level
vulnerabilities that we as an
organization made the decision to accept
the risk
and we get our S1 so here we can really
see okay what's all the dependencies
that went into building this package so
we have the base layers from Docker but
we also have our Java and Maven
dependencies in here and can understand
it's actually a long list of what goes
into the image
and down here the new build provenance
tab which remember that's uh actually a
pretty cool feature because we don't
just have the s-bomb we also have how
was this image built in a way that even
after a lot of time we can still connect
these dots and there you can see okay
the image was built with Cloud build on
those hosts
um that was the entry point for the
build we can see
um the individual steps that were run on
which containers what was executed when
was it run uh what was the outcome of
the individual steps so really good
information for us
okay
now let's go over into the runtime site
as mentioned earlier so we now have a
secure container that we can actually
run on our clusters so in kubernetes we
have this new uh security posture
management feature that's basically the
dashboard that you get and what you can
see here is I have three clusters since
my application has to go through our
secure build process it doesn't have a
lot of vulnerabilities so I deployed a
few things which will raise concerns
we get two things we have to enable that
for our clusters but we get
configuration concerns so where can we
improve our kubernetes resource
definitions and we get vulnerability
concerns for the images that we have
deployed so for example here we can see
that we have a cve for expat 248 R Dash
r0 from the Alpine image and we have a
few configuration images now when you
have a lot of workloads running and you
maybe have more clusters
that's not helping you to drill it down
so that's where you go to the concerned
stuff on concerns we can we have
different choices how we want how we can
analyze these concerns we can
analyze by concern type for example okay
this pod container is allowed to run as
root concern we have five workloads
affected by that maybe that's something
where we want to do a more of an
structured organizational approach to
fix it we can take a look at it on a
namespace level where we can get okay
this namespace this workload has these
vulnerabilities or on a per workload
level
for example the simple Go app has pod
container allows privilege escalation or
really useful sometimes you want to
start with the most critical things to
invest your time wisely the workday only
has so many hours so you have to decide
what you tackle first so maybe we start
actually by the critical problem the
um
the outdated base image
but
to for us to Circle back let's actually
take a look at from our demo app at the
Pod container allows privilege
escalation because I think it's really
useful to see we had a recommended
action
so here security posture management
really gives us directly a
recommendation how we can fix this
problem so we didn't configure any
security context in this plot deployment
so it gives us the recommendation if we
don't need it
a make it explicit and B just disable
privilege escalation so here we just go
back into our Cloud runtime Cloud
workstation sorry go into the
um our deployment
then for this container I really don't
need a privilege escalation
sorry
and just disabled and that's how
we get this continuous scanning in gke
which informs us and we're circling back
to Cloud workstations to then fix the
problem
so
let's
wrap it up
all of the features you have seen today
are available in preview
stuff like
binary authorization actually for a long
time I think
it should be at least preview
you can get started if you want to try
it out yourself with our quick start
tutorials you should check out our
software supply chain security website
to get more information on the on the
individual pieces and what you can do
and how you can use them and I recommend
that you try listen to the other talks
on Google Cloud next on cloud
workstations gke and tors and CI CD to
get a good picture of all the individual
parts that you're using
and that's it thank you for your
attention and enjoy Cloud next
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hello developers are you ready for our
next session
now we're going to hear about seven yes
seven new features that help you
simplify building modern applications so
please welcome representing the
Netherlands and he really does own five
bikes Google Cloud developer relations
engineer vitsevinema
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is
I'm a developer
and I'm an author I wrote this book
building serverless applications with
Google Cloud run
it's a short story about the book it's
um it has a bird and a cover
it's an O'Reilly Animal book so the
O'Reilly doesn't let you pick the animal
they do that for you so it's a book
about cloud computing so yeah I got the
bird
and um and when I first showed this this
book to my my daughter she's five years
old
see um she looks at me
that
did you write a book about a bird
fair question
so I'm like
um no it's about containers running
containers in the cloud
so it looks at me puzzled
did you did you put a bird in a
container
well it's it's sweet right another
another thing I like about being a dad
is that I can make dad jokes now
yeah yeah
I'd like to bring the energy level up so
what do I say to you when there's a duck
flying into you
duck
and I have another one so who's from
Bavaria
I like to say hands okay I learned a
very great dad joke yesterday
um I'm gonna try this in German so well
here Vogel einbein
okay you can Applause yeah yes thank you
thank you
[Applause]
awesome but I'm here today to tell you
about
the features we launched in Cloud
functions and Cloud run
I'll do some live demos I mean what can
go wrong let's get started with Cloud
functions Cloud functions are the
easiest way to run some code on Google
cloud and extend Google Cloud products
all you need to do is write a function
and deploy you don't need any different
experience and you can connect over 125
Google cloud and third-party services
so this is when Cloud functions is
useful if you want to respond to events
if you want to respond and I want to
transform data as it arrives and store
it in a data store or and this is my
personal favorite if you want to extend
Google Cloud products so if you have
some logic in Java put it in a cloud
function and call it from a SQL query in
bigquery
what's new in Cloud functions you told
us you really liked Cloud functions but
you wanted more and that's why we added
more we launched the second generation
of cloud functions it has more compute
power longer processing times and more
advanced
so today you can select up to eight CPUs
and 32 gigabytes of RAM
this is about enabling workloads that
didn't fit on a cloud function in the
past and this also helps we increase the
maximum processing time for HTTP
triggered functions
to one hour a full hour
and finally more events Cloud functions
now supports over 125 event sources
through its integration with event Arc
that's more 10 times more than before so
Cloud functions second generation is
about more compute power longer
processing times and more event
but there's more
do you know that sinking feeling when
you've rolled out the change to
production you discover that you made a
mistake
like I know I do
um I I pushed a small change that didn't
need testing straight to production
I I will I will that maybe that this is
not the time and place to tell you about
that but um
second generation Cloud functions run on
cloud run
I know right that's that sounds
complicated but it has been this way all
along
so Cloud run and Cloud functions run on
the same shared infrastructure but we've
now made it even more explicit that
means you can click through and edit the
underlying Cloud run service and that
includes traffic management to the
revisions the cloud run automatically
creates for every deployment
and that's super useful because
sometimes you make an honest mistake and
you want to click quickly revert like I
did back in 2016.
um
still not a year
now here comes my favorite feature I
really like how you can use cloud
functions to extend other Cloud Google
Cloud products bigquery remote functions
lets you call a cloud function from a
SQL query
in case you're not familiar bigquery is
the the the data the serverless data
warehouse in Google Cloud
and with remote functions you can extend
bigquery with code written in Java
python JavaScript or any of the seven
supported languages and Cloud functions
and that's great for logic that's very
easy to express in a general programming
language but very hard to express using
SQL
let's say you're migrating from Hadoop
to bigquery and you have some logic
that's implemented in Java and you don't
want to prioritize moving it over to SQL
just now or maybe never with remote
functions you put that Java code in a
cloud function and you're good to go
time for a demo
there we go so I created a cloud
function
it's barely readable but I promise that
I'm calling the Google Maps API here to
get the distance between two cities so
let's let's show how that works let's
let's
look at my trip back home
so I enter Munich and Amsterdam it
generates this command for me oh I can
click the button testing Cloud here
oh no reconnect live damage you gotta
love him
click the button again
enter
so authorized of course yes
my trip back home will take 8 hours and
25 minutes
so now I can call this function from
bigquery so I have this query
I'll zoom in a bit for you so from
Munich to Amsterdam Paris Rome Stuttgart
and garching which is this very famous
city nearby
no people from garching in this in the
room that's sad it's 22 minutes away
so there you go
um back to the slides please
so that was Cloud functions
back to the slides please
yes thank you so that was Cloud
functions to wrap up we launched the
second generation and it's more longer
more more compute power longer
processing times and more events and an
improved integration with the rest of
Google Cloud now let's talk about Cloud
run
Cloud run is a fully managed platform
that lets you run your code in
containers
directly on top of Google's
infrastructure there's no kubernetes in
between Cloud run runs containers
directly on top of Google's
infrastructure
and Club run automatically adds more
instances to handle all incoming
requests or events it's very simple and
automated
there's no infrastructure to manage no
cluster to worry about it allows you to
go faster to be more productive
let me put it this way we've
intentionally designed Cloud run
to make developers more productive
and today Cloud run is in Avail is
available in all 34 Google Cloud regions
and in every new Google Cloud region
we've announced Austria yesterday which
is nearby right
hmm us yeah yeah
um in every new Google Cloud region we
turn on cloud run is available from the
gut go
now when when do you use cloud run
services for websites and web
applications use your favorite stack to
build your application using any
programming language access your SQL
database render then Dynamic HTML Pages
you can also use streaming with
websockets it's all included
second is apis and microservices so you
can build a rest API a graphql API or
private microservices that communicate
over HTTP or grpc
and streaming data processing is a very
strong use case Club run Services can
receive messages from Pub sub and events
from event Arc
so this year
we launched Cloud run jobs
and you can think of that as a Quran for
the cloud so a job executes containers
to completion you can start a job using
the API the Google Cloud console or you
can schedule a recurring job and just as
with Services you only pay for the
resources these containers use while
they're running and there's no
infrastructure to manage
so to sum up you can use cloud run jobs
to run a script that performs database
migrations or other operational tasks to
run a scheduled job
think run job or to perform batch data
processing which lost Cloud run jobs
also supports parallel processing
so it's time for a demo now
there we go I will authorize
so
um this is my shell script hey it's
great to have you here it will just Echo
a line in the in reality it will do
something with gcloud or connect with my
database my favorite fruit of the day is
Apple
well that's funny my favorite food is
Apple
Apple
okay good I will save that
and I'll put it in a container so I have
this Docker file from Ubuntu add an
entry entry point script which is the
script I just edited and set that as the
entry point I will just build that into
a container with
Cloud builds
invalid source
[Music]
ah got it I'm in the wrong directory
and now I execute this command again
Okay so
huh
this is this is what happens with live
demos I like it
New Shell this should be
louder to change the difference yes this
will work
there we go okay so this should take 18
seconds
we'll have to be patient
if you know a fun joke tell me I can
share it with the rest
no takers
so it uploaded the source it's building
the the docker image using Cloud build
it's pushing the image
so now
when it's done I can get over to jobs I
click create new job
select the container image
the latest one you can see I tested this
many times it can't go wrong
and give it a name and I execute the job
immediately so this is one of those
three ways to start a job API Google
Cloud console
or you can also schedule it using Cloud
scheduler
and it's already executing
so when it finishes I will switch to the
logs Tab and I will see my favorite
fruit
very exciting demo watching the spinner
hey it's great to have you here my
favorite food is Apple
thank you
I think it's really great when you like
when you like clap when I when I
actually finish my demo back to the
slides please
so in the title of this talk I promised
you seven new features in Cloud run and
before I dive in here's what I'll cover
datadoc integration Health jacks
CPU boost
software delivery Shield you've been
hearing a lot about that today security
recommendations and Cloud deploy and
Integrations so I cheated a bit because
the last one Integrations is actually
two features
first we're proud to announce a
partnership with datadoc around
observability so you can use the
official data Doc in container agent to
send logs traces and metrics to datadoc
feature number two we are introducing
health checks on cloud run and to
understand what those are let's look at
the life cycle of a container so there's
the startup phase when your containers
are getting ready to serve requests and
there's the serving phase when it
actually serves requests
so when does a container transition from
starting to serving anyone knows
it uses a TCP startup probe so as soon
as your container listens on a TCP port
bam it starts to serve requests
with Cloud run health checks you can
customize the probe so in addition to
TCP you can now configure an HTTP probe
and this is useful for apps that start
listening on a TCP Port before they are
actually ready to serve requests
looking at your Big Spring boots app
um we're also introducing a new kind of
probe liveness probes aliveness probe
determines if a container is still able
to serve requests if it's not it will be
shut down and Cloud run starts a new
container so you can use liveness probes
to stop container instances that got
into a corrupt local state or force a
restart after a certain amount of time
feature number three is startup CPU
boost and it helps
improve scaling speed so as you know
Cloud run automatically adds container
instances to handle all incoming
requests that's called Auto scaling and
container startups time is very
important when it comes to scaling So
the faster a container instance becomes
available the faster it can handle
requests
and the faster Cloud run can scale your
service
so to improve your container startup
time you can do one of two things
the first thing is well change your code
to create your container startup time
maybe you start lazy loading
dependencies maybe you try to remove
things that is out of loading so it
starts at faster
and the second thing you can do is well
configure more CPU because usually that
improves the startup time especially
when you're using one or two CPUs that
sounds great right
you pay more and and it starts and it
starts faster and you don't have to make
any code changes
yeah but it's also more expensive so
that's why we've came up with startup
boost
with CPU boost we dynamically double the
number of CPUs we allocate to a
container instance
during startup only
so as soon as the container finishes
startup we reduce the number of CPUs
again so you won't be charged for using
double the amount during the entire
container life cycle
and we've observed that this can almost
cut in half the startup of some
workloads for example when you use
spring boot with one or two CPUs
and I know I can see some faces in the
in the audience you won't believe me so
I will show you
I'm I'm a recovering Java developer so
let's go to My Demo
i i initialized a a spring boot app and
I deployed it to Cloud run
it's uh it's a fairly simple app all I
did was initialize it and added a
endpoint
that lets you admire my web design
skills it says hello Munich
um and I deployed it to Cloud run and it
now says that it starts
in about
um
running jvm running for eight and a half
seconds 8.1 I also added an endpoint
that let me stop the container because
well makes it makes it better to to
collect demo information
um about eight seconds so I can go into
edit and deploy new revision
and turn on
startup CPU boost and deploy it again so
that will take some time and we'll need
to collect the logs again so I have
deployed the same exact container image
and this other service that I've called
spring boost
uh it was funny I thought it was funny
anyway but this one starts in almost
half the time so it's four seconds four
and a half seconds for the day so this
one will scale faster and I won't
pay much more
so that's good let's go back to the
slides
let's go back to the slides
for feature number four
can we go back to the slides please
software delivery issued the security of
the software supply chain is top of mind
today and that's why we've enriched the
built-in security panel with the
software delivery Shield it shows
security information
um for example the salsa level of your
container so salsa is an acronym and
stands for supply chain levels for
software artifacts it defines a level of
assurance for your workload so if you
automatically build from your git
repository using Cloud build you will be
already on level two as Cloud build
captures Source provenance and it signs
artifacts by default
and additionally
it displays vulnerabilities that were
found in your deployed container image
grouped by severity
but we're doing more to help you secure
your Cloud run service we've added two
new security recommendations with active
assist
active assist scans the configuration of
your Cloud run service and it looks for
well recommendations to make and it will
now suggest to use secret manager if it
detects that your environment variables
might contain API keys or passwords so
if you have an environment fireable at
SAS API key or it's SAS password well so
now maybe you want to use secret manager
click here to enable
I think that's pretty cool it also
recommends to use the built-in service
identity if it then if it detects it you
might be storing those basket long-term
service account credentials as a file
inside of your container image I hope
you're not doing that but if you do
Cloud run will tell you
feature number six Cloud deploy is a
fully managed continuous delivery
solution and it lets you manage the
release of your container in a pipeline
so with Cloud builds it was a bit of a
manual work to get that all working so
with Cloud builds Cloud deploy you can
manage that from developer environments
to staging to Productions to production
and it now has direct support for cloud
run
and finally Integrations
I've said this before Cloud run has been
intentionally designed to make
developers more productive
and we're constantly looking for ways to
improve that so one of those
opportunities is to reduce
the amount of manual steps you have to
do with automation so here are two
examples of common tasks that require a
lot of steps to do with Cloud run today
creating a cloud memory store instance
and connecting it to the cloud run
service because you have to add the
serverless VPC connector wire through
the IP to the cloud within service etc
etc
uh the second thing is setting up with
the global external https load bouncer
in front of your Cloud run service with
a custom domain right because that lets
you take advantage of cloud DNA cloud
CDN and Cloud armor
enable easier migrations
both tasks are not hard or complex but
they do require a lot of manual work you
have to read the docs follow a long list
of steps make sure not to click on the
wrong button so Cloud run Integrations
is like that robot that does all the
work for you
it's hard to create a memory instance
and bind it to your service and it does
that for you
so look if you forgot anything else from
what I told you today I hope you're
remembering the amazing dad jokes
remember this one thing
we've intentionally designed Cloud run
to make developers more productive and
we're looking to improve that every
single day
thank you thank you
[Applause]
and if your mirror won't make it any
clearer I'll be the wanna let you know
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi developers we're entering in the home
stretch of our Tech talks and up next I
know I'm super excited to hear about
serverless and sustainability in one
so we'll hear about how switching to
serverless saves on costs and can save
the planet please welcome to the stage
respected leaders of the customer to
customer or C2C community in France
guilla blacker data architect for kafur
on Antoine castex data architect at
L'Oreal
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you for joining the
target of the presentation of today is
to explain you how is it very
interesting for you in terms of
architecture choice that you will made
to save first your money and also the
planet
so my name is Antoine I am working for
L'Oreal I'm here like here I'm working
for kafur I will not do any introduction
about Laurel because I'm pretty sure
already everybody knows very well
L'Oreal so first number one cosmetic
luxury group in the world present in
more than 50 countries with 19 000
employee
and kafu is one of the major Hitler in
France and in Europe and our company are
concerned about sustainability and to
save the The Planets kafu For example
take care of the plastic in the store
and take care also in the cloud to how
you consume our services
and I are friends who are leading the
C2C French Community we are a group that
architects in the large group and we
have a data Lake data warehouse and we
have similar problem can you tell us
more about this problem so the problem
seems to be very simple to solve but we
will see that there is different way to
solve that problem
imagine you are like me and Guillaume
you have some data you have choose a
dedicated cloud provider which I hope
it's it's Google Cloud now you put data
data and more data at the end the target
is to have more and more data but
you really want to know what the data
you have in terms of how many lines of
row where the data is located because it
can be some in sometimes in some place
and sometimes in another place because
of some horizontal security or legal
restriction
but you need some data about this data
I call that metrics usually it's more
metadata but I would say it's data about
data Okay so
the story we have to tell you today is
we are trying to have metadata
every day about the data usage that we
have too much complicated
in terms of what
we will tell you to have this metadata
how much carbon from Frank is consumed
to have this information every day every
day how much cost
and how long it takes to have this
metadata okay
yeah and for some we will have several
Solutions
solution because when you use a cloud
clay provider we have others you have
many times a different way to do the
same thing you can use uh whole services
like VMS and build what we want on top
of VMS or manage or serverless services
with less customization but more
flexible and more managed way to to do
the things
and the first one is the all good way is
the VM what we do in our VM is to in
sequence
request all the projects on our
Organization for all the projects we
request all the data sets for all the
data set we have all the tables and get
the metadata on the tables above the
number of rows volumes and so on and we
do that in sequence and it takes a time
but it finish I think
so imagine you do table by table data
set by data set a company like mine and
the one from geom has a lot of table and
I'm sure you already know because it's
big it takes 24 hours so
okay not that bad but imagine if
tomorrow we have more data remember what
I say in as an introduction I need this
data at least one times per day so if I
if it takes 26 hour
I have a problem so that's my first
problem the second problem I don't know
if it's the case or not it's the cost I
don't know how much money do you have
but okay I see it cost more than four
thousand dollars per month per month
meaning one run per day so it's one run
per day additionally at the end of the
month that's a price so it's not uh one
uh the price of one owner of course and
in terms of CO2 we have a number okay
approximately 200 kilograms of CO2 we
don't know if it's good or bad but do we
have another solution yeah we use
another solution and more mutant
solution we use a solution based on
containers and we use a managed Services
we use app engine Flex to deploy a
custom containers on app engine Flex
what's a approach inflex it's a managed
solution or pass platform as a service
and in my definition is a service that
you have nothing to configure you take
your container you depend your container
and magically is run
Auto scalar according to the traffic on
your on your corner is scale up and down
and you keep always one instance one at
least to be sure to be ready to process
the new request incoming
with app engine we
designed this architecture with a class
scheduler that trigger endpoint on on
app engine that create a lot of tasks in
Cloud task and then in in parallel you
have other Imports to uh on the same app
Engine Services to request the metadata
on bigquery the task for example is
request this project this this data set
and this table and you do that in in in
parallel
and so this is quite different
so the result in terms of time we see
not so big difference so not not very
great in terms of money first great news
okay I can save a lot of money for
myself to doing something else
in terms of CO2 again it's very very
different because you compare two
different kinds of architecture and
different generation of solution but
can we do something better here yeah you
can do something better because app
engine Flex is quite old it's it has
been released I think 10 or 8 or 10
years ago quite old and we are modern
Services is named Catherine children is
a service product so the difference
again for me in my definition that's
again like managed Services you have
nothing to configure easily you can take
your container and deploy it it scale
automatically from 0 to 100 thousands of
instances and especially because you can
scale to zero you pay only for what you
use if you don't use it
you don't have instances and you don't
pay for for it if you start to use it of
course you start to pay and one of the
most popular services for running a
container on Google cloud is Catherine
Cadron is a container based so Contour
also is very popular because it's modern
way to package any application any
business
um
of course as I said
he also managed concurrent requests if
you have a look to cell function for
example with Cloud function you can con
function first generation you can
process only one request on one instance
so if you have 10 requests you have 10
instances and it's not very efficient
with Cloud run you can have a concurrent
processing on the same instance you have
10 requests processed in the same time
and the most interesting feature for me
is the tentative compliance in fact
Clarion implements a keynative apis that
means if we install kinetive on top of
any other Juventus cluster on dke
on-prem or other operator you can deploy
the exact same Contour on and on
connective that's wonderful for the
portability
about the concurrency and the building
why because in fact here you can see
that you start to pay to the blue Parts
when the first requests come in and when
the latest request has been processed
the blue part you can process several
requests in the same time and the great
part in fact the instance is up and
running but no process no requests are
processed and you don't pay for that
maybe Google pay but not you
and that's why it's very important and
very efficient in terms of cost and
processing
and it's what about the architecture the
exact same as app engine Flex
why because you use the exact same
container but Deploy on other platform
again a cloud scheduler endpoints a
first endpoint to create a lot of tasks
and then to have a parallel processing
of the task on cloud run again
and the result is difference so the
number
you can see with increase a lot the time
elapsed to do the job so that's a good
news because remember what I say
normally we will have more and more data
on this data warehouse today next month
next year so it's good to see that
scalability for the future will be okay
we also decreased the money we spent so
another great news for you but also for
me and also in terms of CO2 okay 25
percent less it is very great
so let me give you an overview of the
two result but before that I just want
to say
where are this result coming from very
quickly
first is the CO2 CO2 is coming from the
carbon footprint dashboard of the the
cloud console that you all already have
access to we do an export on bigquery
every day and we use the data billing
also comes from the billing explorer
that is natively available and exposed
into bigquery on a table on a daily
basis and the timelapse is measured
basically on cloud monitoring looking at
the logs the beginning end of the job
and we do the report for you to be there
with you today
so
um
we have the tree evaluation you can see
difference but gilm I am a little bit uh
interesting to know why between two some
recent architecture we have this
difference can you explain me uh the
difference between the past and the
serverless yes yes because it switched
because you use the same partner or the
same architecture and we don't have the
same result in terms of performance in
terms of CO2 interrupt costs in fact as
I said when you use Solutions on the
cloud you have different way and
according to the service and the
solutions that we that we Implement you
have different Behavior as at the end in
fact with app engine Flex you have two
things the first one app engine Flex
never scale to zero that means you have
at least one instance open running
that's why the uh
never scale to zero then when you have a
parallel pile processing of a mini task
the problem is the following with app
engine Flex the scalability is based on
the number of requests is based on the
CPU usage and when you query an API like
bigquery to get the metadata what you do
you wait you perform an apical and you
wait for an answer and for of course if
you wait you don't use CPU
CPU time and you don't scale so much
is based on the number of requests that
you have and because you have a lot of
requests in in parallel you can scale
very fast from from zero instant in the
instance to more than 700 instances into
the during two two hour per days and
that's the difference of cost and speed
but it's just not the only one
difference between serverless and older
architecture or Legacy or standard
architecture I'm sure Antoine we have
one good news for us
a little bonus which is not a technical
one but very important for you so the
choice that you will made and it's
basically the conclusion of this
presentation is very important in terms
of what we call the shared
responsibility model because if you
prefer to do some infrastructure more
than some thermales it is not a problem
we are not saying this is bad we are
just saying keep in mind that you have
something to do that is different than
if you select serverless in terms of
contract of responsibility between new
and the cloud provider okay if I have
the VM if I prefer having the
possibility to customize something but I
also have the mission to update the VM
where if I use cloud run it is not my
job to do that I led that to Google so
it's very important to keep that in mind
but do we have a last bonus here yes yes
also bonus in terms of high availability
why because if you have to have a matrix
every day you have to be sure that your
process run every day and if if not you
have an issue in your following uh in
the following of the Matrix that's why
you want to be high available at least
at original scale where you run your
your app and if you have a VMware
example in fact you need to have an
architecture that make you a resilience
in case of issues of your VM so if you
deploy something in one region we'll
deploy one VM
but if the VM goes down you need to have
other VM up and running to continue your
processing
but you don't need 2vm in fact you need
3vm why you guys you have to
um
to prevent to uh to to face this uh this
pattern you have one instance goes down
the other one is in maintenance and the
third one is ready to serve your traffic
that's why you need at least 3vm in one
zone to be high valuable in one zone now
if you want to be high available at
traditional scale you need to repeat
this pattern for all the zone
of your religion so at least three VM
for season 9 VM at the end
when you have a look to serverless it's
not the same if you have the Habit to
deploy services on serverless in fact
Universal The Zone only the region in
fact you deploy Canada and app engine
why because natively is not deployed on
one zone but in all the zone
of the region so by default and out of
the box serverless products are natively
high available at traditional scale and
remember you pay for what you use
remember also the difference in time of
costs and and carbon footprints for
summaries with children and with one VM
here 9 VM
for me the serverless is really the
future to save money to save the planets
and also to save time to go faster to
deliver values
so thank you very much thank you for
your time if you want to have some
question Twitter LinkedIn also don't
forget to reach us
and I and thank you very very much for
your attention and enjoy your rest of
your day thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
to me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
hey Developers
we are down to our last tech talk that
will be live broadcast also to our
audience on the internet from Europe
Middle East and Africa
and for this last session let's learn
how to easily move from raw data to
machine learning and we'll hear about
this from our Google Cloud machine
learning product specialist kamuma
welcome
foreign
and welcome to the final session on how
to move from raw data to ml faster with
bigquery and vertex AI
first off let me introduce myself my
name is kamuma I manage the customer
engineering team for the South India
region specialize on machine learning
and AI
so let's begin the session how do you
move from data to machine learning
so what are the barriers between data
and machine learning that we often see
with our partners and customers and even
internally at Google which continue to
slow innovation
first let's start with data
data is often big and multi-formatted
which means there are many data silos
copies of data and makes data hard to
discover and extract value from
then aim ml systems are often isolated
from data leading to more needs of
integration security risks and
unsuccessful machine learning
deployments
so first how do you get from data to
machine learning let's look at the data
piece you need the data engineering
steps this includes data ingestion data
preparation data storage and often some
sort of data cataloging
and then you move to data analysis where
you need data exploration data
pre-processing to gain Data Insights
so how do you extract even more value
with machine learning
first you have the model development
step where you do feature engineering
model training
register your models in a model registry
and some type of model evaluation
and then you do ml engineering with
model serving model deployment and model
monitoring with features stored in
between
and finally you have Insight activation
where you could use your learnings from
your machine learning and data analysis
to influence business decisions customer
decisions and serve Downstream
applications
we've also added the horizontal
component of orchestration so you could
automate your ml pipelines and data
pipelines with CI CD
so this slides show how you could build
entire data to ml Journey with data
Cloud Google data cloud and I would like
to say that this is not all of our
services
provided on our platform this is just an
example of some of the tools that you
can use to get value from your data on
gcp
so on my right here you have any type of
data that can be ingested inside gcp and
more so your data could come from
corporate and third-party systems
e-commerce SAS applications iot devices
social media or geospatial data and more
and then it could get ingested on gcp
with data engineering using dataproc and
data flow and I'd like to point out here
that dataproc is a serverless version of
spark and dataflow is a serverless
version of Open Source beam and this is
indicative of all our services where we
try to have a managed version of Open
Source software to have the most open
platform available
next we have data analysis using
bigquery or the data analysis tool of
your choice
you could do model development on vertex
Ai and bigquery ml ml engineering on
vertex Ai and insight activation on
vertex side looker app engine or other
Downstream services
this can help with any Innovation here
are some that we listed but I'm sure you
have some in mind or some are ready in
production so decision making app
development SAS applications exception
management and so on
you also have the horizontal
orchestration layer to automate each of
these steps to scale and put these
models into production we propose here
Cloud composer or vertex AI pipelines
how composer is an imagined version of
Open Source software as well and vertex
AI pipelines supports two open source
SDK tensorflow extended as well as
kubeflow pipelines SDK
and we really designed and built this
platform to meet the needs and expertise
of various users that you see listed
above and more so data Engineers machine
learning Engineers data scientists data
analysis business users to add value to
the customer
so how do you get to this full ml
production system
we had designed a journey from crawl
walk and run this is very high level but
we hope it'll resonate with you
so first we were proposed to start with
vertex AI workbench
vertex AI workbench is a Jupiter based
fully managed scalable enterprise-ready
data science experience with easily
enforceable policies and user management
so we see with our users that they could
get to production ml models faster with
vertex I workbench compared to
traditional Jupiter notebooks and this
is the case because we've added
extension to simplify data access so you
can seamlessly and out of the box
connect to your data source in bigquery
Google cloud storage and other data
sources
we also support In-Place data
Exploration with SQL and Spark queries
from a syntax aware autocomplete enabled
notebook cell
and also we support multiple
environments out of the box
so whether you're using tensorflow pi
torch or spark you could run any of
these engines from the same vertex AI
workbench instance
this means you don't have multiple need
to have multiple servers for different
environments
and this saves you time from maintaining
and keeping running multiple servers as
well and costs
so now that you can crawl with the
workbench how can you walk and start to
train and deploy your models
so this is an illustration of how you
could do this on vertex AI so your data
could come from Big Lake if it's tabular
it could come from bigquery or it could
come from Google Cloud Storage
then you do your data engineering step
you could use one or all of bigquery
data proc and data flow
and then you move on to model training
on automl vertex AI custom models or
bigquery ml
and then you can register your models in
vertex model registry and deploy these
models for batch inference on bigquery
ML or vertex AI endpoints for batch and
live inference to power your Downstream
applications
I'm also now very excited to announce
that model registry on vertex AI is now
generally available
so vertex AI model registry allows you
to have models registered from automl
bigquery ml or vertex AI custom models
so all your models could be in one place
for easy reuse tracking and model
versioning
we also allow you to add labels and
aliases to your models to facilitate
model discovery
another feature is that you could
seamlessly deploy your models to vertex
AI endpoints using the UI or via a
Vertex CI SDK
and finally all this is integrated into
our vertex AI SDK so you really have a
unified vertex AI experience
so how do you really run with machine
learning
we've added here to the previous diagram
the vertex AI pipelines Cloud build and
CI CD block up top
so what this means is that now you can
automate each of the steps in your
machine learning pipeline you could
substitute vertex AI with Cloud composer
as mentioned previously or with another
orchestration tool
same with Cloud build and CI CD you
could use
hybrapositories or is equivalent
we also added feature store so this will
enable you to share features reuse them
and also version your features
here is how a Vertex AI pipeline could
look like so each of these blocks you
see in this diagram is a vertex AI
component and it's a step in your ml
Pipeline and this could all be
orchestrated with additional features
such as runtime parameters and
conditionals
we're also very happy to announce that
now we have 20 plus pre-built bigquery
ml operators available for you
what this means is that previously you
would have to create your own custom
component if you were to use bigquery ml
in a Vertex Pipelines
but now we have 20 plus pre-built
components which are maintained and
supported by Google Engineers so this
enables you to deploy your bigquery ml
pipelines inside production in vertex AI
much faster
and lastly I want to leave you with a
very exciting private preview feature we
have on bigquery ML
B4 you can only use bigquery amount on
structured data but now you can actually
tap into the value of bigquery ml with
your unstructured data as well
this means that if you have a lot of
images or text files stored in Google
Cloud Storage you could lever leverage
big click and bigquery ml to extract
value using machine learning
how can you do this
so I'd like to illustrate how you can do
this with an example of a hypothetical
customer
this is a retail a real estate customer
who wants to predict the click-through
rate of homes on their website
so the current models uses a lot of
structure data like the home location
the size of the house for instance to
train the model
however they may have thousands of
images stored on Google Cloud Storage
that's not taking consideration inside
the model today but this could drive a
lot of business insight
so if they want to use images they would
have to process the images separately
so how do we make this experience better
for them
so right now in private preview you can
create an object table in bigquery where
all the images in Google Cloud Storage
are indexed and you do this simply by
just creating object table this simple
SQL query pointing to each of the
location of your image
next you import your model inside
bigquery so right now you have your
computer vision model imported with a
create model and pointing to the
location of where your model is stored
and then afterwards you run a simple ml
predict using the model and the object
table to create latent representations
in a table which you could then join to
your on your structured data to power
your machine learning model training
so in three easy steps you can actually
have unstructured latent representations
embedded into your new model
and this is the last slide in my
presentation I'll leave you to enjoy the
rest of Google Cloud next thank you very
much
[Applause]
one by one I don't know we've seen so
many things
[Music]
hey so actually we've come to the end of
the technical content that will be live
streamed today but we're super excited
that we have a lot more going on here on
site so I just want to say I hope you've
been able to make the most of it and
thank you all online for your
participation and hope you have a chance
to sign up as an innovator for Google
Cloud so you have access to all of our
Live Events we find out where we're
hosting challenges near you in the
future
and sign up for the Drone Racing League
challenge as well
and those of you here I hope you had a
chance to interact with our Architects
play a couple games
um you know ask some questions get
involved in the Google Cloud community
so I'd really like to personally thank
you on behalf of all of the googlers
here and the local teams
we're looking to really bring more gcp
developer activities to all of you
locally and virtually
so what's happening now
well you are the heart of everything
that we do so that's why we decided to
make some Hands-On workshops for those
of you here locally Guided by our
experts and we'll have one here in this
main room and we'll have one upstairs
and unfortunately for those online we
have to say goodbye but again thank you
and the future is for developers that
we'll see each other again soon
we'll also have a reception for the
local folks here so after your Hands-On
Workshop which remember to get your swag
stamps for we'll then come back and
there'll be some changes and we'll have
a chance to have some food and some
drinks and connect even in a more casual
way so the other workshops are from
polong Ling and other Champion
innovators so that is the building and
end-to-end data and ml solution on gcp
workshop and the second one is upstairs
in our Atlanta room and that's a spark
for data engineers and data scientists
and that'll be with Brad Moreau
so you can take a quick break here and
then join the last workshop and then
we'll see each other for our
well-deserved celebration at the end
back here in the master Ballroom
all right thank you all ciao
[Music]